so wie versprochen ich bin wieder am start was heißt versprochen ich habe
gesagt wahrscheinlich das kann man mich da letztendlich irgendwie drauf
festhagen nee aber wir basteln jetzt ein bisschen weiter
by the way geht meine vorschau monka corona ja vorschau geht ja twitch ist ein bisschen
eingefroren das zeigt mir an noch 220 zuschauer von
heute morgen was irgendwie nicht sein kann sondern sind alle abo box camper
näher das ergibt aber wenig das gibt aber wenig sinn aber ein paar haben
anscheinend wirklich vergessen den rechner aufzumachen weil sie nennen
ich kann nicht sprechen es sind instant 15 leute da soll die ausflüge in hex und
weil man kann man kann files embedden das ist tatsächlich relativ praktisch für
html oder sowas oder für den key das muss man mal speichern das ist recht
nicht recht praktisch aus was ja ja ja ja ja ach du kruse so stripes ja ja ja ja
guck es ist schon ist schon heftig am blinken vor lauter eier ja ich hier warm
drin jetzt klimaanlage anmachen und bei an sich heute nicht so warm draußen ist
aber es ist halt innen drin noch übelst aufgeheizt
gleich wieder spiegel liegt omg passt mal auf passt mal auf
schraubendreher lieg oder was anderes
spception lieg
was mit der musik jetzt los mit so laut von ks übertreibt man nicht das soll
chill sein hört sich das nach chill an vielleicht nach kalt aber nicht nach
entspannt
und die musik sens den lieg oh mist wo habe ich jetzt habe ich das ding in die
kamera gehalten wo habe ich jetzt hingeschaut hier weil ich habe so ein
kleines döschen auf dem schreibtisch da kommt hier kleine sps und mikro sd karten
so rein weil ich habe schon so viel zeug unwiederbringlich irgendwo
hingeschmissen und eventuell vielleicht sogar aufwächte sonst wo ja was kann ich
da noch kann ich da noch liegen
habe ich ja nur irgendwas war ja moment ich habe ich habe nur eine sache eine
sache die sich auf jeden fall die mit jemand auf jeden fall liegen kann weil
das was sehr praktisch ist und zwar knippeck seiden schneider lieg
wester was hältst du eigentlich von not als back end technologie also wenn es zum
projekt passt warum nicht ich bin da also an sich ich finde an sich not
mittlerweile ziemlich gut auch wenn sie jetzt alle auf deno schwören aber das
ganze npm ökosystem wird dafür sorgen dass npm relevant bleibt wenn ich npm
not relevant bleibt mit mit npm habt ihr diese sache mitgekriegt jahre 1
versus jahre 2 diesen package manager wie sie sich alle flamen und wie jetzt
facebook sogar gesagt hat nein zweite version verwenden wenn ich verwendet
nur eins und auf der fette wieder npm und da haben ja die haben auch alle ein
bisschen coq reveal ja probleme gachi bus reveal moment wo ist mein wo sind
meine emotes da oh bis sie groß vielleicht bis sie weiß auf weiß
so immer diese riesigen zangen um seiten zu seite zu schneiden ja das ist
genauso wie der zitronen falter der faltet ja auch immer zitronen oder
besser gesagt eigentlich eigentlich eher massif pence jam
ja wie gesagt ich finde not ja genau also finde not als backend technologie
eigentlich ziemlich gut muss ich halt fragen für was wenn es was ist wo man
eventuell vielleicht sogar sachen hat die man irgendwelche datendefinitionen oder
so wenn man die scheren will zwischen frontend backend und so ist not gut wenn
man generell gut in javascript ist und quasi fast alles kleinseitig machen will
bis auf ein paar sachen halt im backend wo man halt nicht drumherum kommt ist
not für javascript pro auch was ich persönlich mag ja die kombination aus
asp.net core und vue js im frontend das ist so meine persönliche
lieblings kombi ehrlich gesagt das ist aber nicht gesagt dass es die beste ist
dass auch bei weitem weit weit entfernt von die einzigen zu sein ich meine es
gab mal eine zeit da wurde jeden tag ein neues web framework geboren
mittlerweile nicht mehr ich wollte übrigens mal was zeigen zwar also nicht
unbedingt das display das zählt da oben jetzt sag mal leute das display wackelt
oder
das sollte warum wackelt das das ist ein monospace font das dürfte eigentlich
nicht wackeln das ist ein monos phoenix das ist monospace font den habe ich
extra hochgeladen hier guck das ist hack bolt oh moment
gibt es auch hack als nicht monospace
moment doch hack hack ist das ist das auf jeden fall monospace
mal preferences hack regular ja ja da steht da steht plus nicht monospace
dran aber das muss monospace font sein immerhin ich habe extra deswegen hoch
geladen dass das monospace font ist das ist monospace font wir gucken mal wie
ist dieses komische ding mit mass mal hier downloads den scale habe ich glaube
ich gerne anfalls java ist wie ist dieses komische ding mit dem an diese
fonts generiert das war das doch oder ich muss mal gucken nicht dass ich
wirklich keinen monospace font generiert habe select great font hack
hack das ist monospace das ist alles mehr geht nicht man ja auch hier das ist
alles ziemlich gleich breit das ist das ist monospace font warum deswegen frage
ich mich warum warum das wackelt das dürfte als monospace font eigentlich
nicht wackeln vielleicht wegen anti in lesing ich glaube ja eher dass das hier
irgendwelche komischen dinger macht dass das hier mit der mitte das mit der mitte
nicht so ganz mittig hat dass das irgendwie irgendwie rumspinnt ich meine
wir können ja mal aber das sind auch keine lehrzeichen drin also wackeln
sollte es nicht guckt mal wenn ich nehme ich hier wenn ich hier firmware update
hochlade dann das brauchen wir jetzt mal karl ein neues firmware update hochladen
dann so was auch was für eine ip habe ich eigentlich gekriegt
ja ja ja
ich weiß nicht mal was für eine ip habe ich glaube ich glaube die war richtig
richtig weiß gar nicht mal kurz gucken ja doch die war richtig 1 2 2 glaube ich
habe sogar dhcp reservierung gemacht ich wollte sagen ich habe sogar die hat die
hat cp reserviert das ergibt allerdings überhaupt keinen sinn hallo
ja ja ich habe den kram immer noch aus kommentieren das muss rein dass er sich
reconnectet von monka
was jetzt warum ist warum ist er jetzt abgekackt
korul panicked illegal in strife das ging doch gestern
wollte mich das jetzt irgendwie g baden es kann auch nicht gestern wunderbar
funktionieren und jetzt irgendwelche exceptions werfen dass das geht auch
nicht was ist da los monka smoke
c++ logik also also also was wir heute machen also zur auswahl zur auswahl
können ihr könnt euch das sogar ein bisschen ein bisschen überlegen ist und
immer noch wackeln muss erst mal gucken warum wir eben gecrasht ist
what the fuck wo war warum kreischt er jetzt auf einmal was das what the fuck das
ging gestern ich habe nichts mehr geändert wollte mich verarschen
warum ist das was
was ich kommet hier mal in der lupe alles aus lat es noch mal neu hoch nur
eier ja habe ich habe ich irgendwas verkackt oder so
was ist denn los andere einfach nichts dann geht's wieder wahrscheinlich okay
habe ich habe ich gestern noch irgendwas gemacht bevor ich weg bin
außer einsen copy pasted
nee ich habe nix gemacht hier dran ich muss ja auch hier dran nix machen weil
das habe ich copy pasted von einem anderen projekt wo es geht ja ich habe
hier irgendwas anderes verkackt wenn ich müssen wir jetzt irgendwie einfach
einfach schon was der verschmerzen hat servus
wollen sie sie pro mal gucken ob jetzt ach jetzt geht's ich weiß woran es
liegt natürlich natürlich chat ich bin ja auch lowbrane ich habe es gestern noch
gesagt bevor ich aufgegangen bin was das problem ist das problem ist dass wenn ich
das delay raus nehme das ist das was ich gestern noch machen wollte wo ich nicht
dazu gekommen bin welchen staubsauger hast du noch mal den hier wir machen
falls den mott da ist ist ein mott da
einer der könnte mich ein kommando anlegen das wäre äußerst pro
ich glaube wir brauchen ein zwei neue mods da muss mal gucken hier wer immer
hier am start also ich kenne ja die leute schon ja also ich sehe jetzt auch schon
wieder sehr viel bekannte bekannte leute am start also wenn ich wenn ich hier so
durchgucke es macht es natürlich oft am start der könnte vielleicht mal wenn er
gerade wenn er weiß wie das geht den staubsauger command anlegen und
reinschreiben dass ein roborock s 50 ist und danach er generiere ich noch an
amazon link das easy aber hier der moonbeard es ist oft am start den sich
total auf stripes 007 den rock auch der war schlecht da war da war schon eine
nummer unter pains camp wir haben hier wir haben wir hier sonst noch am start
der tanzer natürlich der unser top sub gifter herz 93 auch oft am start
schieße pro sagt mir der name irgendwas kann das sein dass du früher auf
youtube irgendwelche call of duty geschichten gemacht ist irgendwie oder
haben wir mal gameplay geschickt das call of duty mich der name kommt mir
bekannt vor flow 690 auch am start das rope jörn der name sagt mir jetzt nichts
das heißt nicht dass du nicht oft da bist aber zumindest nicht so auf dem chat
gew oz 13 kusch renada ist auch wieder da der ist auch oft da den kann immer noch
nicht aussprechen phoenix ist auch öfters da die nikos ich auch manchmal
mario trader ist auch auf der captain peng sowieso das sei es da ist auch
öfters da rusty sauer auf dass sie total viele leute jetzt ist auch kein perium
habe ich auch schon öfters mal gesehen ja nice so viele leute die man kennt
der twinkler ist auch wieder da
eher ein lurker der name kommt mir trotzdem bekannt vor
pan timbo ist auch auf da no limit x das ist ja exzellent name flow 690 sowieso
den haben wir total oft hier 40 ist auch oft da
ja wunderbar ok also moment sekunde wo bin ich stehen geblieben ok der kram
funktioniert wieder also genau das war nämlich das und ich sag euch gleich was
wir zwar auswählen was wir heute machen können also ich erkläre es muss man
warum das abkackt wenn ich das wenn ich das so mal ist das mit dem das stimmt
überhaupt nicht mal mal upload hier sind die later in da kann gar nicht so oft
eier ausgeben ist das staubsauger geflasht ja wie gesagt ich zeig es fast
jeden stream weil das wohl eines der beliebtesten themen überhaupt im stream
ist staubsauger ja link zur firme wäre gut ich habe das hier
fork den da rand 256 falle tudor habe ich auch guck mal die haben neue releases
was haben sie denn dazu für neue features für den staubsauger
zeig mal her was gibt es für neue features auch guck mal mittlerweile
geht es auch für den s 55 ok neue klinik schedule geschichten aber man kann jetzt
man kann jetzt stockwerke speichern und wiederherstellen das ist natürlich
excellenter kann man kann den man kann den staubsauger ins erdgeschoss tragen
und ihm die map laden und sowas das ist gut man kann jetzt direkt firmen update
machen übers webinterface
ja gibt es sonst noch so das habe ich alles gerade installiert live map
sonst wie die sind hier alter was geht mit denen ab die hauen ja hier am laufen
band ist was raus ja wie gesagt das ist webinterface von einem staubsauger ist
eine karte vom wohnzimmer in dem fall kann es sachen hier aus mit
verschiedenen zonen manuell steuern einstellungen ja und das webinterface
gibt es halt normalerweise nicht ist das der hier kann ich dir gleich sagen ja
weil er ein bisschen andere farbe hat wobei man da gucken muss dass es nicht
die china only version ist da gab es glaube ich irgendwelche probleme mit der
china only version wenn man hier und außerdem ist 300 noch was zu teuer also
ihr müsst gucken dass ihr den ja sowas hier sowas ist ok 250 maximal 300 euro ich
glaube ich habe dem im super mega angebot damals für 250 gefunden und
habt ihr bestellt
so also ich erkläre jetzt erst mal kurz warum das hier fehler warum das fehler
wirft nämlich die sache die ich gestern fixen wollte und was wir heute zur
auswahl haben zu machen das erste ist wir können uns hier drum kümmern dass
solche fehler nicht mal auftreten also sprich wir können gucken dass das
malen auf das display also sprich dass hier also sprich der part des
programs was ja ja eins also was was das display aktualisiert das muss immer vom
gleichen thread aus laufen das ist ein bisschen also dann hat man keine
probleme das ist ein bisschen so ich weiß nicht wer von euch schon mal
windows forms an wendungen gemacht hat oder generell jegliches jegliches gui
framework das möchte zugriffe auf das gui nur aus einem gui thread haben dass
es in die quere kommt die meisten kontrollieren das auch und machen
einfach nicht so kacken ab wenn das nicht so ist das muss man hier natürlich
nicht machen allerdings es egal ob winnows forms wpf uvp qt flatter sonst
egal also alles was multithreaded angesprochen werden kann mag ui
automatisch ui aktualisierungen nicht wenn es von mehreren als gleichzeitig
ist oder generell wenn es nicht aus dem ui thread ist dass das die beschränkung
hast du hier natürlich nicht auf so einem hardware ding kannst du fuddeln und
machen was du lustig bist ja aber man hat natürlich ein paar probleme die man
sich dadurch einfängt zum beispiel wenn ich hier in meiner main loop was male
und da oben beim update was male dann kommt dass ich in die quere und bei
diesem hardware passen passen klein controller ist halt einfach sobald es da
probleme gibt da ist nichts mit irgendwie exception abfangen oder sonst
was da ist instant crash angesagt fertig wobei ich muss mal gucken ist
überhaupt exception handling da eingebaut hier das muss ich jetzt mal
kurz ausprobieren aber ist haben die standardmäßig exception handling da
drinne sekunde das muss man kurz ausprobieren
kurz kurz checken ob exception handling drinne ist weil wenn es eh aktiviert ist
kann man das er auch benutzen ok also throw standard argument
ne invalid argument exception ne ach du scheiße wie geht das in c++
exception einfach so kein q ich weiß nicht so und jetzt catchen wir die auch
ne wie c++ throw exception wie geht das ich weiß ich weiß gar ich habe noch nie
eine exception geworfen in in in c++ wie geht das überhaupt
hast du was so 20 einfach der int was zum warum kann ich einfach den int
throne
das ergeben okay dass es c++ da muss die sachen keinen sinn ergeben das passt
schon deshalb ich habe ich aufgegeben irgendwie dass das den ok dann dann
throne einfach 20 was auch immer das heißt so was beknacktes dass das
funktionieren pro 20 ok so jetzt gucken wir mal ob es expe exception handling
catcht ob das aktiviert ist standardmäßig interessieren also die
sache ist die das hier wirft ein fehler und normalerweise kackt es dann ab
es sei denn man behandelt den fehler dann nicht normalerweise ist das aus
in so microcontroller environments gar nicht aktiviert dass man exception
werfen kann gucken ob die das standard ob die das
aktiviert haben ich lache einfach mit ich verstehe nix
jetzt schwierig ist jetzt ne okay gibt anscheinend kein exception handling
jetzt auch übrigens wisst ihr was was was mega nice ist weil ich hier letztens
gefunden habe man kann hier in der in der config datei vom projekt kann man
folgende sache reinschreiben das muss ich euch mal zeigen dass nämlich ultra
praktisch man kann sagen monitor filters und dann lade ich noch mal hoch und es
passt mal auf was passiert das ding kann die ausgabe die debug ausgabe diesen
stack trace also sprich wenn der esp 32 abkackt
mein was mein exception händler passt nicht echt nicht warum so alles gut
passt doch
so jetzt passt mal auf was was diese sache macht das ist richtig richtig gut
jetzt kreis guckt mal hier seht ihr es dieser filter esp 32 exception decoder
dieser filter map mir den stack trace vom esp 32 zu meinem source code der sagt
wo die exception aufgetreten ist das ist richtig poggers
normalerweise steht da nämlich einfach nur irgendwelche hex werte drin
so und jetzt sehe ich es ist aufgetreten looptas das ist die main das ist die
main loop alles klar in vogue abort ok terminate also es ist aus
irgendwelchen gründen abgekackt wahrscheinlich weil ich einen fehler
geworfen habe alles klar
invalid argument ist das eine exception
keck das eine exception aber kamer thrown
also mein exception händler muss nur eins passen
max heute wieder z plus plus gar kein ich habe auch keinen bock auf z plus
plus ach so wenn du int wirst wirst du entfangen ja das ist natürlich das dover
wenn catcht das ist tatsächlich exception händler ihr habt recht ich war
zu zu sehr scharf im kopf allerdings ist die frage warum kann ich was andere
thrown außer exception und kann z plus plus blies warum soll ich den int
überhaupt thrown warum gibt es dann nicht eine basic exception so was kann
ich nicht einfach sagen standard exception und da irgendwas rein hauen
ne das geht natürlich nicht das wäre so das wäre so einfach ok exception
händling ist an alles klar aber das ganze wieder ausmachen sehr schön also weiter
im text ich war gerade dabei zu erklären warum das hier abkackt also das kackt
ab wenn das hier zu schnell durchläuft und ich schreibe hier was auf das
display und dann schreibt er hier was auf das display oder aber noch schlimmer
der der main thread ist gerade im schreiben auf das display dann wird
unterbrochen und hier schreibt was auf das display das mag er nicht da kommt
er nicht mit klar das heißt die logische variante dazu ist und das ist
das was ich gestern eigentlich noch machen wollte dass man irgendwie
zusätzliche klasse bastelt oder so der man einfach diese sache hier übergibt
also sprich was gemalt werden soll und dass dort dann alle sagen 100
millisekunden eine schleife läuft die das malt oder alle 16 millisekunden wer
60 fps haben will meinetwegen wenn es wer meider braucht das da drauf und dann
hat man nicht die probleme da können sich die die platz nicht in die quere
kommen also sprich wenn ich alles von einem thread ausführe gibt es nicht so
probleme dass ich das hier malen male und hier male und sowas gleichzeitig also
koa eins macht nur das und koa 2 macht nur das können man auch so machen also
mein die idee ist eigentlich welchem koa das läuft ist eigentlich egal wichtig
ist nur dass die dass die mal operation synchronisiert passieren quasi in der
richtigen reinfolge von einem thread aus und dazu würde ich einfach noch einen
dritten noch einen dritten tausen wir nennen es nicht thread man nennt es task
dann würde ich einfach noch einen dritten taus dazu starten der im
hintergrund alle 100 millisekunden einfach malt was in der queue drinne
steht oder sowas wie viel herz hat das display eigentlich ehrlich gesagt ich
glaube es gibt gar nicht sowas wie sowas fertiges mit das hat keine
refresher im eigentlichen sinne ich ich refresche das hier jedes mal wenn es
refreschen soll das ist quasi das ist quasi g-sync wenn man so will nur mit
dem unterschied dass es halt ein bisschen kleiner ist limitiert wird das ganze
höchstwahrscheinlich durch die übertragungs rate zum zum display
irgendwie max mache seit einem jahre ausbildung zum fach informatiker für
anwendung natürlich kann immer noch nicht programmieren hast du ein paar
tips also wenn du was hast du ein jahr lang gemacht wenn du seit einem jahr
fach informatik anwendungsentwicklung lernst und noch nichts
programmiert hast und was haben was haben die dir dann beigebracht
ich meine irgendwas muss ja gemacht haben mein chat auf dass man aber man
sachen besprecht sprechen dass wir es zeigen kann
also ich meine irgendwas muss ja irgendwas müssen sich ja machen
gemacht machen lassen haben
kaffee kochen ein bisschen was halbwegs sinnvolles aber ansonsten was ich für
tips habe ist im prinzip so wie bei allen an programmiereinsteigern allgemein man
sucht immer am besten ist du suchst dir ein projekt was du gerne machen will
sei es webseiten sei es desktop anwendung sei es irgendwie server script sei es
irgendwie microcontroller gedöns sucht dir irgendein bereich aus der dir spaß
macht kennst du da fällt dir da irgendwas ein also hast du irgendein
bereich der dir spaß macht übrigens wenn du antwortet schreibt mal etwas dabei
dass ich sehe ich gucke jetzt nämlich ein bisschen hier drauf hast du irgendein
bereich der dir spaß macht dann kann ich dir das besser empfehlen
so also das ist das ist die erste das ist die eine sache die man machen können
dass wir das hier multithreaded machen was heißt multis werden multiplex
synchronisiert machen das ist das eine weil ansonsten geht es kaputt
die andere sache die wir machen könnten ist wir könnten ein kleines web frontend
zum update hochladen basteln denn die sache ist ja die aktuellen muss ich ja
updaten also auf diese art und weise und das ist nicht so ganz allgemein
verträglich ich meine erklärt mal irgendwie in dem 0815 k noob
kein 0815 k noobs machen wahrscheinlich mit esp 32 nix aber erkläre mal
irgendeinem dass er dieses kommando braucht um eine neue firme hochzuladen
ich glaube in den web interface mit upload button oder zumindest mal zumindest
mal gucken wie man eine webseite ausliefern kann ist glaube ich nicht
verkehrt dann könnte man das ja noch ein bisschen noch ein bisschen aufbohren
ja excellent aber ich würde sagen wir machen das erst mal ein bisschen
multis wir machen das erst mal ein bisschen multithreaded dass hier die
sache nicht mehr abkackt wenn ich das durchlaufen lasse also das ziel ist dass
das hier nicht mehr abkackt wenn ich das delay raus nehme also wenn ich das
delay rausnehmen und dann hier was schreibe so und ich überlege gerade wie
wir da jetzt am besten anfangen also wir machen erst mal kurz den ganzen
krempel hier zu
ob man nämlich jetzt net habt ihr übrigens den den stack trace eben
gesehen das ist richtig nice studierst du informatik nie das ist das ist richtig
nice ja übrigens ich überlege gerade kann das kann das farbe ausgeben kann
das farbe ausgeben
kann das farbe ausgeben das muss ich jetzt mal gerade ausprobieren
ja vorn passend passend fürs print fv a hier
ich rauche mal ein beispiel hier ich will mal gucken ob das farbe ausgeben
kann ja so was genau kann das farbe ausgeben also wir geben jetzt ja ja mal
in was ist denn das hier ist das rot das 31 33 das rot wir kommen ob er ja in
farbe geht geht eier ja in farbe
und juli schon ob eier ja in farbe geht du hast die prüfung bestanden
exzellent kratz wie wäre es mit einem shell skip bei der als argument einfach
nur der fahrt angegeben werden müsste wie für was
oh ja ja hier exzellent eier ja in rot so muss das sein funktioniert man kann
farben ausgeben okay das ist natürlich das ist natürlich sehr nice
wenn man farben ausgeben kann das gefällt mir dass das das werden wir
das werden wir benutzen ja ok also kommen wir mal zu der eigentlichen
multifade in geschichte zurück also was ich jetzt vor habe ist da muss ich ein
bisschen muss ich ein bisschen muss ich ein bisschen in mich gehen
was ich machen wird ist das display ist immer noch weiß ach so ja das auf dem
display weiß es ist klar das ging ja das war ja escape das war ja escape
sequenz für die konsole auf dem display moment wie auf dem display kriege ich
das folgendermaßen da muss ich hier sagen text color können wir auch mal
machen gucken dass wir das auf dem display dunkel kriegen text color tft
plank tft red gibt es irgendwie dark red oder so dark grey red probieren wir mal
aus ob jetzt das ist ob es jetzt auf dem display rot wird guckt mal sagt mal
leute nervt euch nervt euch in der vorschau das blaue licht was blinkt oben
rechts oder geht das weil ansonsten crop ich das bild noch ein bisschen weiter
in obs
es geht auch mal in rot excellent
jetzt haben wir ein rot so muss das sein aber das wackelt immer noch warum
wackelt das denn das stimmt irgendwas mit nicht was haben wir denn trost ring
was haben wir sonst noch vier printe printeln haben wir noch oder kann ich
da kann ich ja nichts übergeben wo ich hin malen soll egal wenn wir lassen es
jetzt mal das darf jetzt mal wackeln und gut ist dass wir mal ein bisschen zu
rande kommen also was ich mir zu überlegt habe ist folgendes wir machen
eine klasse die nennen wir mal
display ich mache ja aus prinzip nur heller dateien weil cpp dateien sind
overrated cpp dateien braucht kein mensch
display ich mein man kann in der heller falls auch
alles machen wozu brauche ich cpp falls das meine dateien über mehrere dass
mein code über mehrere dateien ja exception endlich hat funktioniert also
ich freue mich schon auf diese modulgeschichte vielleicht wird 10 plus
plus mal irgendwie ertragbar sondern ist man display constructors brauchen wir
einen den man aber in line warum soll ich den da kommen wir können wir machen
es mal ein bisschen ordentlich so also wir brauchen constructors für das für
die display klasse jetzt muss ich mal überlegen wie man das am besten machen
ja wie gesagt exception endlich hat es hat funktioniert ist gut practice alles
in einer natei zu machen ernsthaft aus meiner sicht ist es dass
vielleicht nicht bei den c++ fans aber ansonsten so ziemlich jede sprache der
letzten 20 jahre hat ein metadatensystem und keine zwei dateien
guckst du in ruby an guckst du in java an guckst du in jeder x
beliebigen sprachen an so zeug wie header files gibt es nicht mehr man hat
alles schön auch diese sache dass man eine klasse definiert und dann hier
unten die sachen dafür dann dann implementiert ist auch wir normalerweise
will ich hier oben gucken da jetzt habe ich zwei jetzt habe ich hier quasi zwei
sachen wo ich finde ich kann es einmal da finden und ganz einmal da finden also
sprich ich hoffe mal dass er sich das mit modulen in c++ in zukunft ein bisschen
ein bisschen bessert alles ja so also das heißt wir brauchen jetzt folgendes wir
wollen ich versuche mal ich versuche mal so die klasse an sich so ein bisschen
zurecht zu basteln also was wir brauchen ist wir brauchen private erstmal einen
händel zu dem zu dem display ansonsten ansonsten klappt das klappt das ja nicht
also also erstmal include moment wie heißt das hier arduino und display
wir brauchen erst mal ein händel zum display nicht sprite tft ist das
ne moment wie ist das ding doch das ist so irgendwie so ach hier da ist es genau
also nennen wir es mal display oder hier tft wir machen den c sharp private style
so wir brauchen auf jeden fall händel zum display dann brauchen wir eine sache
die wir irgendwie sowas wir nennen wie lub oder so du baust eine drohne auch
nice den ganzen programm konnte ein komplett immer macht es wie javascript
ich warte noch drauf bis es web pack für c++ gibt die machen da quasi alles in
eurer teil übrigens wisst ihr was ich mich frage warum sowas nicht gibt für c
plus plus wahrscheinlich weil es zu kompliziert ist für javascript gibt es
ja bubble babel wahrscheinlich babel weil weil ihr wahrscheinlich eher babel
weil es übersetzt aber das nimmt alten javascript code und stellt in stellt
neue features also angenommen man selbst hat nur einen browser mit javascript von
vor sieben jahren aber möchte neue javascript features verwenden dann kann
das hier quasi die neuen javascript features einen zur verfügung stellen
und dass man neue javascript version braucht indem die das quasi zwischen
einbauen also zum beispiel könnte man damit uns
jetzt mal auf c++ zu übertragen man könnte mit c plus wenn der compiler nur
c++ 17 kann dann bräuchte es so einen transpiler was
daraus c++ 20 macht das wäre cool aber ich glaube das geht nicht weil c++ zu
kompliziert ist und keiner bock hat so ein krab zu implementieren
du hast auch vor jahren mal ein video zum informatikunterricht in schulen
gemacht kann das im moment zu nur zu 100 prozent nicht beschädigen ja blöd
dass es immer noch so ist in manchen bereichen ist aber besser besser
geworden so also was wir brauchen noch eine
methode denn wir es mal display oft wie ist eigentlich die richtige bezüge wie
macht man es eigentlich in c++ mit ich mache metoden klein fertig so display oft
brauchen wir display on weil wir wollen den ganzen kram hier an und ausschalten
so display on und display oft können wir schon mal relativ einfach machen
nämlich damit da können wir das nämlich auch aus main raushauen
vielleicht ist vielleicht ist das zu copy paste jetzt nicht die beste idee
lassen wir es mal so display oft ist das da und display on ist das da genau so
ich mein man könnte man könnte auch man könnte auch privat machen
heute set brightness habe ich brightness richtig geschrieben kann das wort immer
nicht aussprechen ja tatsächlich set brightness und da gehen wir irgendwie in
so dass man irgendwie so machen das kommt dann da rein
flupp wir machen wir nicht in in wir machen ein beid weil dann geht es auch
nur bis 250 und dann die helligkeit und dann sagen wir nämlich hier einfach nur
noch set brightness display auf null und dann hier ist set brightness display
50 das ist doch schöner bei b gut naming ja beid für b also was ist das
problem wieso nicht in und nicht u in acht macht keinen unterschied also ja
macht ob beid oder u in acht macht macht keinen unterschied kann auch char nehmen
oder sowas oder oder ich kann auch und nehmen auch ok macht kommt alles aufs
gleiche raus wahrscheinlich ist das unter unter der haube eh alles u in so und
jetzt können wir mit dieser klasse schon mal display an und ausschalten so jetzt
jetzt jetzt jetzt geht's weiter so wir brauchen auf jeden fall irgendeine
methode die malt void draw die definieren die die machen wir mal hier unten die
wird ein bisschen länger
wobei wir machen wir machen das alles in line warum soll man extra extra
sachen machen das doch beknackt
obai mal gucken also wir brauchen irgendwas was malt dann dass auf das
display brauchen wir sonst noch c++ ja ich
muss das ganze arduino zwar ist halt nur mal c++ kann ja kann ja auch nicht nicht
so als hätte ich da als wäre ich da irgendwie großartig scharf drauf
irgendwas mal trough loop dass ich dass ich weiß was macht was brauchen wir
sonst noch lass mal lass mal eben nicht gehen wir brauchen einen task handle auf
jeden fall weil wir dann eigenen task task starten vielleicht soll ich die
variablen oben machen und die privaten methoden unten oder so sondern task
handle brauchen wir auf jeden fall
schreib selber da kein test dafür nein für die meisten anderen sachen
ehrlich gesagt auch nicht so ich glaube das reicht erst mal so also von der idee
hier was wir jetzt machen ist ach so nee das wichtigste das wichtigste habe ich
glaube ich ganz vergessen so und dann also ich mache jetzt noch mal hier so
die in den die definition und dann erkläre ich mal was ich was ich
eigentlich was ich eigentlich vor habe
das funktioniert noch nicht ich erkläre es noch mal also was war was ich was ich
vor habe ist folgendes ich mache eine klasse display die die die lege ich hier
oben irgendwo an display nennen wir es display die startet im hintergrund ein
task was macht dieser counter aktuell nur hochzählen die startet im
hintergrund ein task und nur aus diesem task heraus wird das display angefasst
das hat den riesen vorteil dass ich keinerlei probleme mehr bekomme mit
greift gleichzeitig auf das display zu und wie man das ganze dann benutzt so wie
ich mir das vorstelle ist folgendes man hat hier irgendwie eine display in der
display klasse klasse und wenn ich jetzt auf das display was malen will mache ich
folgendes dann sage ich display da mache ich nicht mehr dann mal ich nicht mehr
direkt hier drin auf das display sondern sagt so was hier display ach so im
moment das hier muss das hier muss public dann sage ich display draw so und da
stecke ich jetzt eine funktion rein in der ich male so so in der richtung so so
ungefähr stelle ich mir das vor was dann passiert ist diese also das ist eine
anonyme funktion also sprich ich stecke die anweisung was ich malen will hier
rein speicher mir das irgendwo und alle 100
millisekunden gucke ich danach ob es was zu malen gibt und dann malte aus diesem
thread hier also ich mal jetzt nicht mehr direkt ich glaube ich hoffe man kann mir
voll ich hoffe vor allem das funktioniert was bin ich mir nicht so
ganz sicher deine emotes gehen nicht ffz konfiguriert sich gerne mal um also
sprich ich schiebe diese funktion hier in meine display klasse als auftrag das
ist quasi das sollte ich nicht tron nennen das ist vielleicht soll ich
drac u oder so nennen irgendwie sowas in der richtung also sprich der übergibt
die anweisung was er auf das display malen soll hier in diese klasse und hier
läuft an den task alle 100 millisekunden und malt das ist nämlich unglaublich
praktisch dann komme ich mir mit dem malen auf das display überhaupt nicht
mehr in die quere wäre es nicht auch sinnvoll in die
helligkeit verändern zu können also die funktion popular doch könnte man machen
aktuell schalte ich nur an aus kann kann kann kann man kann man machen kann ich
kann man vielleicht verschieben oder so ja wäre auch sinnvoll hast du recht aber
ich will es hier unten kann man ein bisschen platz haben dass ich alles sehe
ja ist vielleicht sinnvoll dass das so verschieben so so so weit von der idee
damit das funktioniert wäre sowas ich ich klaue mir das ein bisschen von so
allen von den meisten gui frameworks die ich kenne die machen das nämlich auch
so also zum beispiel wir bleiben aber windows forms und paint gibt es da so
ich zeige euch mal das beispiel wie sind sie scharf aussieht und so ungefähr
will ich sowas ähnliches will ich hier auch bauen so wenn man in c-sharp
das beispiel ist ja absolut wir hallo und paint was blöd hier da ist es doch
genau also sprich in c-sharp kann man für grafische oberflächen in windows forms
kann man so kann man hier on paint überschreiben das ist im prinzip was ich
so ein bisschen was ich hier mache und dann wird diese funktion hier wird von
aus dem hintergrund raus jedes mal aufgerufen wenn zeit da ist das fenster
neu zu malen und dann kann ich selber malen also sprich so ungefähr sowas in
der richtung sowas in der richtung will ich will ich jetzt hier auch bauen
moin michael 50 billionen
was was schreiress oh das aber nicht gut da michael schreibt gestern abend hat
sich wer in mein twitch chat account eingeloggt eingeloggt trotz zwei factor
authentifizierung und bits in wert von 450 euro kauft und leuten donated das
ging weil mit meinem twitch verbunden mit meinem twitch verbunden ist und man
sich deshalb nicht einloggen muss schreibe ich dafür den twitch oder paypal
support an ihr beide würde ich machen also erst mal erst mal twitch support
kann man paypal nicht zurück zurück machen zurück buchen irgendwie
wie hat er denn das denn gemacht trotz zweifach der authentifizierung
wieso nicht einfach mutax mutax machen kann man auch machen
dann muss man sich bei jedem traum irgendwelche mutax lock geschichten
kümmern und wenn du es mit dem mutax machst habe ich noch ganz anderes
problem wenn ich hier in der main loop drin bin und in mutax gelockt habe und
die main loop abschieße zum update machen und er hängt im mutax drin da
kann ich hier nie wieder malen wahrscheinlich
komisch sehr aber ich würde ich würde es auf jeden fall beide beide supports
anschreiben so wie übergibt man jetzt diese
funktion hier an wie übergibt man jetzt so lambda funktion an an draw wie
macht man das in c++ gescheit standard function oder sowas gibt es da
ich habe es so hier draw, was ist das denn
ich bin noch hin und her gerissen soll ich das hier oben alle soll ich das
alles hier oben inline machen oder nicht ich mache das alles inline scheiß drauf
ganz t++ geflügel da ich mache das alles inline zack
geht wieder ah hat sich hat sich ffz umgestellt
der hat zwei fakte authentifizierung erraten
ich hätte eigentlich gedacht wenn der code bei dreimal verkehrt eingegeben
wird dann verfallte oder so komisch also mit inline meine ich nicht inline inline
also ich meine nicht inline so also inline das ist das schlüsselwort sondern ich schreibe
das alles hier oben in der klassendefinition warum warum soll ich das
da unten hinschreiben so also wie übergebe ich da jetzt eine
ordentliche ordentlichen zeige auf die funktion
conversion from lambda to void gibt es nicht warum nicht warum kann ich mein
lambda nicht zu void konvertieren ok dann machen wir das hier das ist das ist
t++ standard das das muss so gehen function ich weiß noch nicht ob ich da
irgendwelche parametern für brauche sagen wir erstmal void f
bild geht das jetzt exzellent das funktioniert
wie weit bist du gekommen ich habe gerade erst richtig angefangen also was ich
gerade mache ist ich versuche die probleme die ich habe dass wenn ich hier
aufs display zugreife und hier aufs display zugreife geradezu beheben in
dem ich noch einen dritten task starte der für mich malt wo man quasi in die
queue was reinschreibt was er malen soll und dann malte er alle 100
millisekunden oder was heißt q wo ich macht ich macht überhaupt keine q hin
das bescheuert ich mal einfach das letzte gewinnt der letzte mal auftrag
gewinnt fertig wozu wozu soll ich irgendwie mal ist egal ob das verloren
geht das letzte was geschrieben wird soll aufs display fertig alles andere
mit fit verworfen gut ist also brauche ich noch ein händel für meine function
funk besser na jetzt was ich in t++ jetzt auch nicht genau verstehe ist ist
das und das das gleiche also sie schabt wäre das nicht das gleiche sie schabt
wäre das hier an initialized und er würde beim ersten zugriff drauf
compiler abkacken aber ich weiß nicht ob das in t++ auch so ist
wahrscheinlich nicht malen so es eben war es function f q ist auch gefährlich
ich hätte es mit der queue so gemacht dass ich maximal fünf elemente oder so
drin speicher wieso nennst du dich heute wo bloß und ich
mags fps viel früher das hat das hat mit früher und heute überhaupt nichts zu
tun ich habe diesen twitter account erstellt
für mich privat zum twitch gucken ich wollte damit überhaupt nichts machen und
irgendwann habe ich angefangen zu stream oder hieß ich halt bloß und habe
ich mir gedacht ich finde es eigentlich gar nicht schlecht ich behalte das bei
so jetzt speichere ich mir die funktion hier das wird wahrscheinlich so nicht so
ohne weiteres funktionieren aber schauen wir mal so und jetzt und jetzt können
wir schon mal testen ob das ganze ob das ganze klappt in dem ich eine schleife
starte im constructor der
der das aufruft und dann hoffe ich dass es nicht abkackt darf man konstrakte
auch in sein schreiben also sprich ich mache jetzt quasi einfach nen task task
create machen wir mal auf dem speziellen kerne wie gesagt der sp 32 hat zwei
kerne und ich lasse das auf kerne 0 laufen weil anu ino läuft auf kerne 1
also sprich mein eigentliche logik läuft dann auf kerne 1 und der rest läuft auf
kerne 0 man muss allerdings ein bisschen aufpassen
ja der ist stimmt er hat einen low power mit 8 megahertz aber den lassen wir
jetzt mal aus vor mit korn 0 muss man ein bisschen aufpassen weil korn 0 macht
also der cpu kerne 0 kümmert sich auch um bluetooth wlan und solche geschichten
also den darf man nicht überlasten aber alle 100 millisekunden was auf display
malen das sollte der nicht überlasten das kriegt er das kriegt er glaube ich
schon hin also function schon auch nähe das funktioniert ja wieder nicht weil
c++ ist man kann ja keine function pointer keine member function pointer
machen c++ egal ich schreibe das erstmal fertig dann heißt es nicht
keine traur traur task stack tiefe ja keine ahnung was wir da für eine stack tiefe brauchen tief
würde ich sagen 4096 kein schlimmer so konsta stimmt man können
parameter übergeben okay sehr gut priority eins händel ist das was ich
vorher schon angegeben habe oben und als cpu core nehmen wir null was das hier
macht ist folgendes hier erstellt einen zweiten task oder zweiten thread oder
wie auch immer man das nennen mag auf mit priorität 1 auf dem ersten core und
in dem händel das händel zu diesem task braucht man zum beispiel um den task zu
stoppen um den einzufrieren oder irgendwelche sachen damit zu machen
deswegen das müssen wir uns speichern sonst funktioniert es nicht richtig so
und das ist c++ add its best natürlich kann man keinen keinen pointer übergeben
an eine methode hier in der klasse dass das funkt also ich sollte mir die sache
erst mal anlegen sogar aber funktioniert trotzdem nicht weil er sagt oh nee es
nicht erlaubt gescheites c++ gescheites zusammenarbeiten mit c ist nicht gewünscht
man muss das ganze static machen weil da geht nicht anders und an static void
parameter und das einzige glück was wir haben ist dass man den user parameter
übergeben kann und ich sage ihm jetzt ok erstellen den neuen thread neuen task
führe diese methode da drin aus also da ist ja gerade noch nichts drinne da wird
jetzt eine endlosschleife reinkommen weil das soll unendlich lange im
hintergrund laufen und übergebe den zeiger auf die klasse mit hier als
parameter das heißt ich muss mir jetzt meinen zeiger auf die klasse zurück
karsten zu auf meine eignen das ist ich kann es gar nicht erklären so so
bescheuert ist das dass ich wieder verwenden kann also weil hier weil das
static ist kann ich den zeiger auf die klar auf die instanz nicht verwenden
deswegen muss ich den parameter erst mal wieder karsten in die display klasse
zurück weil doch warum arduino nicht spdf ganz einfach weil die meisten
libraries für sensoren displays und so gedönst war ich verwende die meistens
gibt es halt für arduino es gibt viele auch für free air tross beziehungsweise
spdf aber ich habe mich mittlerweile so an das arduino zeug auch gewöhnt und
zumal man ja sagen muss im prinzip ist es ja das gleiche dass das ist ja oben
drauf gesetzt denn den eigentlichen vorteil den man hat mit spdf es hat man
kann ein paar sachen besser konfigurieren als wenn man den arduino
den arduino aufsatz drauf hat wo manche sachen fest sind geht nicht
this trolling nein das funktioniert nicht wie gesagt das geht nicht es gibt ja
sogar eine richtige fehlermeldung für es gibt ja sogar also ja gut natürlich
funktioniert weil ich static gemacht habe ein static funktioniert ja eh das
funktioniert es gibt ja sogar extra es gibt ja sogar eine extra fehlermeldung
für und zwar dass nicht static infinite use of non static member function c plus
plus erlaubt es keinen klassischen function pointer auf methoden aus einer
klasse was die sich dabei gedacht haben weiß ich nicht
die haben sich auf jeden fall da nicht sonderlich viel gedanken gemacht um
interop mit altem c code mit doppelpunk mit doppelpunk geht es auch nicht also
wie gesagt ich habe es ja gestern im streamer gezeigt das funktioniert in
keiner in keiner art und weise und ich hätte eigentlich erwartet dass die
zusammenarbeit von c plus plus mit c recht gut durchdacht ist und ja ich weiß
auch warum sowas hier nicht geht weil der eigentliche metoden aufruf eben nicht
so ist sondern noch mit mit der klasse intern davor also wenn wenn c plus plus
sowas hier auf ruft dann ist es nicht so wie es hier steht sondern in
wirklichkeit ruft c plus plus sowas dann hier auf display
draw loop bis und dann die parameter parameter 1 parameter 2 also das ist das
was intern c plus plus daraus macht deswegen stimmt die signatur hier auch
nicht überall man kann sich hin aber ganz ehrlich warum habt ihr nicht
irgendwas eingebaut was es im hintergrund miteinander verknüpft dass
ich diese dieses gedöns nicht machen muss in in cute haben sie das gelöst
indem sie ganz viele template geschichten drumherum gebaut haben dass
es doch geht aber dass es standardmäßig nicht vorgesehen ist es
eigentlich auch ziemlich doof was ist der unterschied zwischen dem feil und
doppelpunkt doppelpunkt der feil greift auf also im prinzip ist das hier ein
pointer und du löst du dereferenzierst den pointer greift auf das objekt hinter
dem point dazu das ist der feil doppelpunkt doppelpunkt ist du greift
auf statische sachen von der klasse zu
oder namespace ja das ist ja auch doppelt belegt lull so wie so wie so
vieles doppelt belegt in c plus plus ich frage mich ich frage mich immer noch
warum die so gerne auf spitze klammern warum die spitze klammern so gerne
haben so also wir haben jetzt einen neuen thread
gestartet mit einer endlosschleife drin das ist alles was wir gemacht haben so
und wie gesagt nachdem ich hier static nicht auf die klasse zugreifen kann muss
ich jetzt folgenden hack machen ich weiß nicht ob es eine schönere variante
gibt weil die referenz auf meine klasse kriege ich hier als void parameter rein
fragt mich nicht warum ich hab mir die sachen nicht ausgedacht das ist halt
so ich muss es auch nur benutzen und das kann ich dann wieder karsten zu meiner
klasse so und ich muss es hier selbst nennen anstatt des weil das ist ein
schlüsselwort und das ist schon belegt das darf ich nicht verwenden ist das
nicht schön gute sprache so und jetzt ist hier im
prinzip selbst das gleiche wie des weil ich das hier drinnen nicht verwenden
darf muss ich selbst verwenden exzellent ist das gar nichts ist eine tolle
sprache so so jetzt habe ich in endlosschleife jetzt muss ich erst mal
sagen fau task die lei 100 millisekunden alle 100 millisekunden das display zu
refreshen reicht so und nun kann ich sagen function aufrufen
so
ok es kompiliert schon mal da ist aber irgendwas irgendwas faul dran
achso es kompiliert ok ok wir gucken mal ob mein wir gucken mal ob mein
multithreading zeug funktioniert wir machen mal eine ausgabe so hallo von
thread ja habe ich es genannt tron task also von der idee her sollte ich jetzt
die alle alle 100 millisekunden die ausgabe bekommen
hallo von thread tron task moment habe ich den thread überhaupt gestartet
exzellent gestartet habe ich den gestartet überhaupt mein display das
konstrakter der soll funktionieren gucken ob ich das jetzt richtig
gedacht habe es gibt ja diese ringleuchten mit dem raspberry pi kann
man die nicht ansteuern sagt der raffmon weil er keinen timer hat um die
ansprechung zu koordinieren aber mit dem arduino gehts kann ich dafür auch in
esp 32 wenn ja der esp 32 hat ein ziemlich guten hardware timer
water water so scheiße was was ist jetzt
was hast du für schmerzen
ich weiß was das ist null ich muss checken ob das null ist ich weiß woran
es liegt eigentlich ganz klar guck mal ich versuche eine funktion aufzurufen
diese eventuell nicht gibt ich muss gucken ob das null ist weil ich starte
ja den task hier und hier setze ich die funktion zum ersten mal ich versuche
was auf zu aufzurufen was null ist das kann ich funktionieren so jetzt gehts
passt auf leute jetzt gehts also der esp 32 hat du hast beim esp 32 mit
timer gar keine probleme da du hast so viele timer du weißt gar nicht welchen
timer du nehmen sollst aber der hat einen ziemlich präzisen hardware
hardware timer kannst du nehmen also wenn es der arduino kann kannst in esp 32 auch
und im esp 32 kannst du noch ein bisschen mehr rumspielen aha sieht besser aus
jetzt muss nur noch kommen hallo von ja sehr schön guck mal hallo von
threadro task exzellent funktioniert also sprich ich habe jetzt im
hintergrund jede 100 millisekunden was laufen was meine malaufträge
abarbeitet gut ich meine das ist ein das ist ein print line auftrag aber ich
meine immerhin schon war das ist ja auch schon mal was so und jetzt kann ich da
drin malen wie mal ich denn da jetzt am besten ja ja drauf sind wir hier so
image
so jetzt malen wir mal hier drin wir machen wir machen mal hier noch dass ich
das nicht jedes mal hinschreiben muss wir machen hier noch mal eine funktion
void keine ahnung war ja ja irgendwie muss ich es nennen so und da malen wir
das alles rein und jetzt sagen wir hier drin einfach nur
bra ah ja ja so habe ich ach ja nee das kann nicht funktionen ich habe noch
was vergessen oder wait a minute warum funktioniert das kann auch
eigentlich gar nicht funktionieren ach hier ach moment ich habe das display
zweimal angelegt nee nee nee das ist nichts in uns weg der sache aber mal
gucken ob das funktioniert wenn das funktioniert wäre echt wir
wobei eigentlich müsste eigentlich funktionieren schauen wir mal aber das
ist auf jeden fall nicht in uns weg der sache das ist dann nicht so schön
gekapselt das machen wir gleich noch anders ich habe ich habe eine idee wie
wir das machen so funktioniert es jetzt oder kackt jetzt ab
ok ist es malt schon mal nicht hallo von doch es funktioniert ist ja nice so
aber es trotzdem nicht schön weil ich will ja nicht eine display klasse haben
und hier oben noch mal meine display und sprites definieren müssen das ist ja
natürlich das natürlich super super beknackt ja
was für ein display das ist ein tt go t display board und das hat als display
muss man nachgucken ein ein ips st 77 8 9 v ein 1,14 zoll display ok das
funktioniert aber schön ist es nicht wir machen das jetzt so ich habe ja
vorhin das beispiel gezeigt wie es ist wie es ist bei windows forms machen so
ähnlich so ähnlich machen wir das jetzt auch oder im prinzip so wie man wie das
fast jedes framework macht wir übergeben hier wir bekommen hier in
parameter das nennen wir so was wie ich weiß nicht was es für ein typ wird
ehrlich gesagt ich denke das weit das nennen wir irgendwie
draw kontext oder so kontext und damit malen wir und damit malen war das
eigentlich eine gute gute idee was verdient man eigentlich mit einer
abgeschlossenen ausbildung als fahr informatiker nur so eine grobe zahl und
ob die gehaltangaben im intern schippen sag mal eine gehaltangabe weil es kommt
ganz extrem darauf an in welchem bereich was du machst und am allermeisten
eigentlich fast in welcher region du wohnst
ansonsten kann alles sein das kann alles sein von 20k bis 150k übertrieben aber
in beiden richtungen übertrieben aber es kann das also das kann nahezu alles
sein je nachdem was du machst wo du es machst und in welchem land und in welchem
bundesland und welcher region
und wie gut du mit einem arbeitgeber verhandelt hast ja das ist mir wurden
1200 euro nette das ist ja der witz das ist ja der witz so also der sinn und
zweck ich brauche irgendwie ich muss irgendwie sowas hier rein bekommen in
meine malenmethode probieren wir das mal aus ob das funktioniert so wie ich mir
das vorstelle also sprich ich gebe jetzt hier
es ist wahrscheinlich auch nicht sinnvoll das breit jedes mal neu anzulegen
wahrscheinlich sollte ich das breit lieber einmal am anfang anlegen dann
wird das ganze nehme ich auch noch schneller
ich das hier mal
moment wo habe ich meine funktions an die ok jetzt brauche ich hier als
definition das da
kompiliert das hier nicht abläuft mir noch gucken ob der kram kompiliert f
gleich geht nicht warum weil hier auch
breit rein muss ok kompilierter kram jetzt wir haben ja alle gelernt wenn es
kompiliert dann geht es auch
schau ja ja schau ja ja kommt dahin das kommt da oben rein
alles ist nämlich noch viel einfacher so display und das kommt alles da rein
kompiliert das jetzt aha sieht schon mal besser aus zwar mal big brain visual
studio coach multiselekt was nicht funktioniert hat
hallo warum nicht aber fürs code mach ok dann eben nicht so klappt es jetzt
ach nee tft with height funktioniert natürlich nicht aber das müsste damit
genauso funktionieren
wo war was tft was not declared ach so ja ok das muss ich meine display klasse
machen natürlich jetzt tft in it ist ja logisch meine display klasse
machen tft in it und ich muss sagen und ich muss
sagen dass er das display einschalten soll display ist display on display
einschalten so und da kann ich jetzt nämlich
diesen ganzen anderen schmodder hier rausschmeißen den ich hier noch habe
da wird mein main auch ein bisschen übersichtlicher wieder das hier mache
ich mal ganz weg das machen wir dann spät dann machen wir hier display display
oft machen wir aber nachher ich will das mal gucken ob es funktioniert dass das
malen geht hier auch nicht das mal kommentiere ich erst mal aus und gucke
ob es dann funktioniert
uc plus plus oh ja ja das herzchen kann man sich jetzt durchtreiben
ach so chat ich wollte mal chat gucken also durchschnittsgehalt 39k stehen bei
step stone ok was passt ab was step stone bei step stone steht brutto das ist
beispielsweise für frankfurt jetzt relativ wenig und sie hat das es malt
nicht nein warum alt ist nicht
es funktioniert nicht leute eierjahr wird nicht gemalt
warum nicht
aber er sagt hallo von thread eierjahr warum malt er nicht
ja also 39k im jahr ist je nach region bestimmt ok also 39k ist zum einstieg
je nach region ist das vollkommen in ordnung nach ein paar jahren und in
frankfurt ist es deutlich zu wenig
hat man die schon mal versucht abzuwärmen ja immer mal wieder aber nicht
sonderlich mit viel energie
aber warum malt es denn jetzt nicht
das bezieht sich auf den flash raffmon ja aber es gibt davon glaube ich keine
16 mb variante schick mir mal ein link zur 16 mb variante
pushpoint warum was hat er für schmerzen also warum
ich weiß was das wichtigste habe ich ja vergessen
ich habe die größe nicht gesetzt ich habe die ich habe die größe nicht gesetzt
leute display on das also display on scheint zu funktionieren ist die
hintergrundbeleuchtung an ich habe die größe nicht gesetzt hier sprite
8 jetzt tft tft breite und tft höhe soll jetzt jetzt müsste es funktionieren
was ist los schaust du gerne die streams an ja das schön auch wenn du es nicht
verstehst vielleicht drei ich dazu bei wenn du dich für das thema
interessiert das ein bisschen mehr versteht aber wenn es dir gefällt freut
mich natürlich trotzdem so jetzt jetzt müsste es funktionieren weil ich jetzt
habe ich die größe ok komm an ist denn jetzt
what the fuck was denn jetzt schon wieder für ein
problem das kann doch nicht sein aber warum ist das immer abscheißen
das ist i3 wm was hat er denn für schmerzen wo scheißt wo scheißt er dann
überhaupt ab hätte ungleich null und wo kackt er ab display drohlo tft sprit
delete sprite
wo kackt er ab ich glaube moment ich glaube ich habe immer weiß color depth
so ist doch eigentlich alles passen ok also die color aber kann ich hier mache ich doch creates sprite kann das
sein dass ich das hier irgendwie als als pointer rein rein schieben muss
gachi bass am moment das hier kann so schon mal nicht funktionieren kann es
ja nicht zweimal setzen
das kommt immer ganz kurz echt man kackt da woanders ab vielleicht
ok schauen wir mal
ok display geht schon mal an
ok ok
ok moment wo kackt er ab der sagt der sagt bett hat was will er mir damit
sagen korrupt hat was was welcher kopf ist korrupt ok ich mach da ich mach da
irgendwelche ressourcen zuordnungsmäßig mache ich da irgendwas mache ich da nicht richtig also
wir können die sachen kann ich schon auf der anderen seite man das muss ich nicht hier machen wir machen
so ein bisschen übersichtlicher push image ist ok ich weiß dass es hieb ist aber er hätte nein
das ist nicht hieb es hätte ungleich null es hätte nicht hieb die haben sich wahrscheinlich
auch verschrieben push image push sprite das ist doch eigentlich vollkommen in ordnung
ok wir machen mal c++ login ich habe keine ahnung ob das ob das hilft wir übergeben
das als pointer ich weiß nicht ob es irgendwie sinn macht aber machen wir jetzt einfach mal
pointer ich breit wir übergeben es jetzt als pointer weil es c++ ist und da point hat man
ob das jetzt funktioniert oh warte achso eier weil pointer weil pointer und so ok
excellent ach ne das muss man auch so mache ja ja ja ja ja passt jetzt ob das jetzt funktioniert
saved ruined we sind nicht bei bot bros ich habe mir das so schön easy und und und
architektur mäßig schön vorgestellt wie das hier funktioniert aber irgendwie funktioniert
nicht und ich weiß gerade nicht so genau woran es liegt ok
einfach point an leute einfach point dann und gut ist ich habe legit absolut keinen
passen schimmer warum es mit pointer geht und und als value nicht ich weiß es nicht
aber als pointer jetzt wahrscheinlich kopiert er nicht alles richtig auch gut excellent funktioniert
nice guck mal jetzt ist der coach schon viel viel übersichtlicher und besser geworden weil
das einzige was ich jetzt machen muss ist bei dem ganzen kram ist hier drinnen zu schreiben wobei
wir vielleicht es mal ordentlich benennen wenn es nicht so was machen wir also unser ziel ist
dass wir jetzt dem ding noch ein bisschen mehr funktionen beibringen also sprich wir machen
nicht wir schreiben da ist nicht immer ja ja hin sondern wir geben mal ein paar sinnvolle
debug messages aus so nach dem motto wir haben wlan gesetzt unsere ip ist sowieso so und das
heißt wir machen wir machen sagen wir mal zwei zwei verschiedene bilder machen wir also wir
machen einmal ein bild für fehler und einmal ein bild für für ok ja ja können wir ok was
ist ich nehme immer ganz gerne joy pixels emojis was haben was haben die schöne bilder für fehler
oder info was haben die für schöne bilder für info wir machen jetzt mal ja ja kurz weg wir
werden es überleben leute nein das ist doof ah hier das ist gut info immer die vielen sechst
joy pixels ich will mich nicht registrieren ich will es einfach nur runterladen warum muss
ich mich registrieren ok easy 10 minute mail create account create account tak email
excellent joy pixels continue create account alles klar wenn ihr es so wollt machen wir
einen fake account seite neuladen seite neuladen hoffentlich kommt das anbar 10 minute mail
rechtsklick mit grafik speichern ja aber da ist es wahrscheinlich nicht transparent
scheinlich anzukommen monkeys oh come on schickt die mail oder die filter das wir können den
code erraten 1 2 3 4 5 6 ist bestimmter vielleicht ist der code 6 5 4 3 2 1 auch nicht
ich glaube den können wir nicht erraten so ohne weiteres ah krass bakmi nord.com fight
and share logins aha für joy pixels.com tja ah da ist es your account ist gedenkst ok
code excellent da sind wir whats your name lul url kw company omega lul nein save changes
wie save changes sehr schön und jetzt lasst mich endlich die emojis downloaden please info
braucht das info emoji da 64 save gut so habe ich jetzt gespeichert jetzt gehen wir auf die
andere seite um uns dort ein passendes c-array zu generieren aus dem info zeichen make download
genau dann holen wir uns das hier raus flop copy paste in unser image file ok das ist 64 mal 63
das kann ich weg machen weil das habe ich dabei geschrieben wie groß ist das bild 64 mal 4
wenigstens wenigstens mal eine sache sinnvoll so info also wer schon immer mal wissen wollte
wie den emoji in bytes aussieht das ist das info emoji in bytes info breite info höhe in dem fall
64 und 64 exzellent jetzt kann man nämlich auch noch ein info bild ausgeben nicht immer nur
ajaja ausgeben und jetzt machen wir hier mal nicht in trau ajaja wir machen trau also welcome
message nie trau trau boot oder trau also sprich wir zeigen jetzt infos an wenn das ding startet
so nach dem motto wir holen jetzt eine ip wir haben folgende ip bekommen wir sind folgendes
wlan connected wir haben die und die urzeit also quasi hier während in den start-up macht zeigen
ein bisschen bisschen status sachen an übrigens ich muss mal kurz chat durch scrollen weil ich
vorhin die hälfte übersehen habe hat sich derjenige noch mal gemeldet wo ich vorhin gesagt
hat er wissen wollte was ich für tips habe für anwendungsentwicklung nach einem jahr noch
nichts noch nicht programmieren ich hoffe ich habe ihn nicht jetzt direkt verschreckt weil ich
gefragt habe was hast du denn jahre lang gemacht also falls du noch da ist habe ich nicht so gemeint
da muss man gleich mal sagen das war jetzt nicht irgendwie böse gemeint aber damit ich dir was
richtiges raten kann wie gesagt muss ich dich mal äußern was für bereiche dich interessieren
wie findest du den neuen song von den ersten habe schon mit oder kenne ich nicht der umut
schreibt er hat den komp tier security plus ich habe keine ahnung was das ist was ist das
kommt kürzlich an wie schmerzmittel oder so kommt tier security plus aha big brain zertifizierung
ich sehe schon excellent high highly secure du hast letztens mein versand track so in playser
umgeschrieben als funprojekt war ganz lustig nice cool gibt es das irgendwo zu sehen wie ich
sag mein versand track ist auch so ein ding was schon ewig lang weitermachen weiter machen will
ich gehe gerade mal den chat durch weil ich habe bestimmt einiges übersehen
ja wie gesagt back in die nord brauche ich nicht ich habe jetzt das andere schon weg account
gemacht was jetzt den nuke holt in den ganzen nicht schlecht für meine anwendungszwecke hier
für meine heim mini-server geschichte hat sich nicht gereignet weil es kein pc express hat
meinst du noch okay meinst du fragt kängin meinst du oder ist es kängine ist wahrscheinlich eher
kängin meinst du normales informatik studium lohnt sich nach einer anwendungsentwicklung
ausbildung noch kommt drauf an wenn du mehr theoretische sachen wissen möchtest oder vielleicht
auch in irgendwie in andere richtung gehen willst dann warum nicht es muss das kam in
allgemein nicht sagen wenn du allerdings zufrieden also wenn du glücklich bist mit dem was du machst
oder man gute gute arbeitgeber hast und da auch sachen machst die dir gefallen spricht ja nichts
dagegen also wirst jetzt beim studium jetzt nichts lernen instant wo man sagen muss ja das das hat
dich unbedingt mal gebraucht informatik studium hast du sehr viel theoretische hintergründe du
kannst dann beispielsweise mathematisch beweisen dass irgendwelche sachen korrekt sind oder so
was brauchst du im alltäglichen leben nicht unbedingt wobei manche sachen denke ich sind
ganz sinnvoll zum beispiel so die so das abschätzen die laufzeit von log von algoritmen und so was aber
das ist was dafür muss man nicht unbedingt informatik studiert haben
so
so ok also wir wollen jetzt ein bildchen malen also draw welcome message machen wir jetzt das hallo
hallo von thread können wir wegmachen weil das weiß ich jetzt ja dass es funktioniert laut font
das laut font können wir auch einmalig irgendwo machen und gut ist das müssen wir auch gar nicht
alles doppelt und dreifach machen ehrlich gesagt das können wir alles einmalig irgendwo setzen
und gut ist aber wir lassen es erstmal drin so jetzt malen welche den info info info info höhe und
info als grafik so und dann brauchen wir eine message wobei warum wir machen es gleich als
aluino string dann malen wir eine message da unten drunter unter das bild also kontext
kontext trost ring also sprich wir malen jetzt hier unter das unter das bildchen wir malen jetzt
den info bildchen und hier unten drunter schreiben wir dann irgendwas hin so nach dem motto booting
habe folgende ip bekommen habe folgende uhrzeit trost ring also einmal den message malen an 0 0
nicht an 0 0 an 0 an 0 info info höhe einfach auf 70 und gut ist und font haben wir gesetzt
brauchen wir nicht gut jetzt müssen wir nur noch message ist not captured excellent alles klar
messages captured gut also das heißt wir über wir geben jetzt hier mal ein paar sachen aus bevor
wir ja ja malen also wenn wir also wir starten wir starten holen uns wlan zeug ok also sagen
wir jetzt hier draw welcome string message nehmen wir die ip zum beispiel sagen wir so was hier
ip ist wifi ip local ip aber sagen to string so und jetzt sollte der beim starten ausgehen was
wir für eine ip bekommen haben auf dem display schauen wir mal ob das funktioniert da bin ich
gespannt ob man gefurtert was hier gemacht hat das alles tut so kommt jetzt unsere ip
ip ip ein bisschen lang
geht das nicht oh oh wo ist das problem ok
was habe ich falsch gemacht warum geht es nicht open ich kann der kann der kann die
schriftart nicht laden hier das muss obendrüber noch der kann die schriftart nicht laden hier
da lull das muss ich ganz am anfang machen wobei ganz ehrlich macht das einfach hier rein wobei
das geht wahrscheinlich nicht das geht wahrscheinlich nicht hi aus dem lörg wenn den moin bootloop ja
der kann die der kann die font nicht laden um die message anzuzeigen ich muss quasi vorher hier
noch das fallsystem laden gucken ob die font da sind und jetzt und jetzt funktioniert es auch so
upload jetzt wird es auch funktionieren tritsch primes hat leute habe ich ganz übersehen
dankeschön für den sub zu subscription dankeschön ich gucke jetzt mal ob ich was übersehen
habe hier steamlabs streamlabs so malte ja ja guck mal hier das war aber nicht meine ip also
er hat was gemalt aber die die die ip war falsch ich warte ja auch gar nicht auf die ip hier muss
das hin systema wohl nebenbei gucke ich mal was ich für was ich für subs übersehen habe ip
liegt 0000 hast mal bock auf ein communityprojekt ja klar warum nicht zum beispiel wenn ich hier für
mein admin board eine webseite bau wo man firmen hochladen kann wenn wir da irgendwelche html
pros hätten so habe ich noch irgendwas übersehen resub heute morgen habe ich ein paar übersehen
aber jetzt nicht ja hackt hackt mich 0000 moment leute ich habe mich geguckt hat die ip angezeigt
hat sie hat jetzt die richtige ip angezeigt ja hat es excellent
sehr schön ich kann es nicht so einfach gesetzt wobei doch ich kann ganz einfach
gesetzt heute ich habe doch in mein update server habe ich doch restart eingebaut ich
kann einfach restarten über über einen html aufruf ja pass mal auf zack woop woop woop
restart das habe ich doch extra für so was eingebaut wo ich kann nicht an den an den
controller dran komme restart und restart wunderbar
jetzt gucken ob die ip stimmt jetzt hier ip stimmt ja nee ich habe wieder nicht aufgepasst
gerade noch mal restart und jetzt zugucken ja nice die ip passt auch ganz genau auf
bildschirm drauf es ist die richtige ip es ist die richtige ip ergibt sie auch hier aus
das ist das ist ja auch die ip von wehler das ist die richtige ip passt passt alles ja sogar
htps richtig big brain weißt du was das für ein akt war bis der shit bis das ota über
htps funktioniert hat das war dass das da habe ich da mich ein paar tage dran rum gewurstet
bis das getan hat zumal es nur eine library für htps webserver auf dem esp 32 gibt und
die ist ein bisschen buggy die hat ganz gerne mal endlosschleifen wenn man nicht aufpasst
ipv6 bin mir gar nicht sicher ob das ding ipv6 kann so das gefällt mir ehrlich gesagt
jetzt schon ziemlich gut wir haben hier oben so diesen ganz ganz rudimentären in it in
it krempe den wir übrigens auch so machen können und danach macht der wifi wartet bis
wifi gesetzt ist zeigt die ip an dann startet er den update server bringt das da machen
wir auch ganz oben fällt mir richtig gut excellent die urzeit können wir noch ausgeben wenn
er die urzeit wenn er die urzeit bekommen hat das hier sind die sachen für update da
gehen wir noch mal die urzeit aus wenn er die urzeit bekommen hat wie kann ich denn
feststellen ob das ding die was wird hier gebastelt also funktionalität an sich macht
das ding nix aber also noch nicht aber was wir jetzt gebaut haben ist erstens dass man
das display gut ansteuern kann und zweitens dass man update machen kann über übers wlan
dass man übers wlan update machen kann und eine statusanzeige bekommt auf dem display
wie weit das update ist by the way das sollten wir vielleicht hier nochmal wieder ein kommentieren
das ganze das war im prinzip brauchen wir das alles gar nicht mehr so wie wir es hier
haben das da brauchen wir nämlich alles gar nicht mehr sondern sagen welcome temp
temp plus ulein und ich kann sehen wie das machen plus ulein für zwei für zwei zeilen
text ist das ist hier nicht ausgelegt um es zu übergeben probieren wir mal aus ob es
so von progres plus von 100 prozent upload so jetzt schauen wir mal ob es tut mit dem
update jetzt jetzt wird kein aiya angezeigt sondern das infosymbol aber da kann ich auch
mit leben aiya wird es ja in der endlosschleife schon angezeigt und bei way ich muss unbedingt
wenn wir aiya ja trauen da muss unbedingt ein text hin nämlich da muss unbedingt ein
text hin nämlich einen counter weil ich will ja sehen dass das dass das alles funktioniert
und dass sich das auch nicht in die quere kommt oder so aber erstmal gucken ob das mit
dem update funktioniert per update machen so jetzt sollte der eigentlich wenn er update
anfängt den progress anzeigen ist das wort da ich habe ich habe mich aufgepasst er ist
irgendwo irgendwo gecrashed ach ich weiß woran das liegt wahrscheinlich weil es wirklich
parallel läuft moment warum ist er gecrashed jetzt draw welcom
hallo max wie geht's was ist das für eine progammiersprache das ist das ist leider c++
habe ich jetzt irgendwo müll gemacht
das mit dem update das kann ich ok es du kannst es mit python oder lua programmieren aber
so richtig so richtig schön geht das am besten mit arduino beziehungsweise mit mit oder auch
mit dem native entwickler kind blöd hat er denn geuploadet ane moment wo mecke er denn
warum kümmerst du dich beruflich war im ausruf zeichen beruf ich habe das mal versucht zu
erklären ok das ganze ist gestartet jetzt versuche ich noch mal update hochzahlen wo
ist er denn jetzt am verrecken warum verreckt er jetzt ok update startet eins was hat er
für probleme warum geht mein update nicht was hat er jetzt jetzt wird es nicht durch
warum war warum will er denn warum will er mein update nicht machen ich mein es funktioniert
ja er zeigt ja die ip an er zeigte die ip ok warte mal ich zeige mal mehrere sachen
an wir zeigen mal die ip an und wir zeigen dann noch mal etwas anderes an vielleicht
kackt er schon mal am zweiten ab hier unten zeigen wir hier unten zeigen wir noch mal
die urzeit an elper time ne ne ne er time vielleicht kackt er da schon ab also ich finds
aber am besten ganz ehrlich ich bin bei weitem kein c++ fan das wisst ihr ja aber mit c
und c++ geht das wirklich am besten auch was ressourcenausnutzung und zugriff auf die
ganzen hardware sachen moment mal warum kackt er warum kackt er ab beim zweiten mal wo ich
male was ist da los warum kann er einmal malen und das zweite mal kackt er ab und und und
warum ist moment mal ihr stimmt doch irgendwas nett ihr stimmt doch irgendwas nett irgendwas
hab ich hier vergessen warum ist die farbe auch falsch
die farbe ist auch falsch von meinem icon ja vielleicht ist ja nicht die farbe falsch
warum ich dann ein paar eier ja brauche beim anderen nicht leuchtet mir nicht ein
ich weiß ich glaube ich weiß woran es liegt ich glaube ich weiß woran es liegt als erstes
müssen wir mal hier hingehen und sagen aber ich hab doch die farbtiefe sieht das sieht
das wirklich so kaputt aus ich hab doch die farbtiefe gesetzt stimmt da nicht ich hab
doch die farbtiefe hier gesetzt farbtiefe felsbein schwarz hat er für schmerzen warum
kackt er beim zweiten mal ab das war noch alles in ordnung farblich okay ich hab da
irgendwo logikfehler drin nutzt keine metrien keine test für deine projekte ich wusste
nicht wo ich hier großartig was mit mir trinken und test machen soll auf der kiste ne ich
bin ich bin ein print f debugger so was hat er was hat er für probleme also der update
er ist jetzt erstmal egal also ich mein wisst ihr was sein kann dass ich den kram löschen
muss danach okay wir machen wir machen das anders wir machen das anders also wir legen
das nämlich das ist eh performance mäßig voll für den arsch was ich hier mache wir
legen das einmal an am anfang also hier wir legen das einmal an so und damit das richtig
funktioniert also wie kriege ich das da wie kriege ich das jetzt als klassen variabler
da oben rein lasse ich will das im konstrakter befüllen wie kriege ich das rein so so ne wie
kriege ich das wie kriege ich das zugewiesen was deleted function was zum was willst du
von mir warum kann ich das nicht zuweisen aber vielleicht weil es nicht lange genug
lebt oh wir müssen ich wir müssen mal wir müssen wir müssen mal c++ features verwenden
es wird jetzt ein bisschen hässlich leute tut mir leid ja schert schert pointer gucken
ob das funktioniert schert oh jetzt wird es eklig leute schert pointer sprite so moment
jetzt oh gott jetzt wirds hässlich jetzt wirds hässlich so ach moment das macht mir auch
anders man macht ja auch übrigens es wäre viel zu einfach von c++ wenn man wenn man
den schert pointer direkt so initialisieren könnte da muss man muss man muss sagen standard
make schert es gibt ne extra ne extra factory funktion dafür lvl und es ist nicht selbst
an der Stelle sondern es ist this aha jetzt ok so so so wobei fill black lasse mal weg
bildet das jetzt aha das bildet das ist schonmal gut solang es kompiliert ist schonmal
ist schonmal auf jeden fall nicht verkehrt ok wunderbar ok also das das gefällt mir
schon besser und jetzt punch und gleich null und jetzt guck ich dass ich das hier übergebe
sprite kann ich das direkt so übergeben nein wie kriege ich wie kriege ich so ein pointer
von einem pointer also es ist ja ein schert es ist ja ein c++ schert pointer wie kriege
ich davon jetzt den richtigen pointer einfachen und nope sternchen kann es ja nicht sein
ein sternchen und was ernsthaft
was the fuck da muss ich noch mal da bleibt mir nichts
ok wir fragen wir fragen gleich mal google wie man das richtig macht
das sieht noch kaputt aus als vorher das ist doch kaputt also ich glaube ich weiß woran
das liegt moment das liegt jetzt daran dass ich die beides beides nicht richtig habe
offenbar hat schert point eine get metode warum war doofe frage warum impliziert konvertiert
schert pointer nicht zu pointer für interop mit altem code wäre das ist es so einfach
gewesen ah yes das sieht gut aus jetzt so und jetzt mal schauen ob jetzt ob jetzt auch das
zweite drohr funktioniert please plus rng ane give energy plus rng darf man ja nicht
mal plus rng darf man ist ja ist ja tos plus rng monka tos ok give energy ja plus was auch
immer fall fett das jetzt funktioniert weil der typ gebannt ist das sieht gut aus das
funst der typ ist gebannt ja ernsthaft so ich weiß beim besten will nicht warum es
jetzt geht da gibt es auch dieses miem das da it doesn't work why it works why ganz
ehrlich genauso geht es mir auch gerade ich ich kann es nicht erklärt ich weiß nicht
warum es besser ist das über den schert pointer zu machen als über den normalen pointer aber
es ist anscheinend besser so und was habe ich gerade gelernt selbst es hat einen get
get get und das kann man jetzt einfach so übergeben sehr schön ja wunderbar wunderbar
da kann man c++ wieder weg machen aber aber ich muss sagen stert ein sternchen und war
schon gut gebt zu leute ihr hättet nicht gedacht dass es funktioniert 1.1.1970 gut das liegt
daran weil wir nicht lange genug warten wir warten nicht lange genug bis ntp die zeit
rausgerückt hat ntp server haben wir den hier wir müssen einfach ein bisschen warten bis
ntp die zeit rausgerückt hat wir können ja mal wir machen jetzt einfach nur schleife
ein endlos endlos schleife einfach ganz low brain mit einem delay wobei wozu wir machen
das einfach in die main loop und machen dann ein delay von 500 millisekunden rein und dann
werden wir sehen ob er die uhrzeit setzt eine referenz auf einen pointer ist das nee das
hier ist nen das hier ist nen pointer auf das sprite und und der shared pointer wird
damit einfach zu einem normalen pointer konvertiert naja chris downhens da müsste ich ja nen da
müsste ich ja nen jahr warten 1970 bis 1900 warum ist es jetzt wieder falsch rum kann
er sich mal entscheiden wie das mit der farbe aussieht warum ist die farbe jetzt wieder
falsch rum ich verstehe es nicht das kann doch nicht sein das bild einmal so rum und
einmal so rum ist ich weiß woran es liegt das liegt das liegt nicht an den farben das
liegt nicht an den farben passt mal auf das wird jetzt auch nicht richtig funktionen das
liegt daran dass ich das dass ich glaube den bildschirm nicht nicht kläre kann das sein
ich kliere den bildschirm nicht und das deswegen malter drüber und es spakt rum ja guck das
wird jetzt auch nicht funktionen der malt jetzt drüber und malte immer weiter drüber
ich glaube ich glaube das funktioniert nicht funktioniert so nicht richtig ich glaube also
daran daran liegt auf jeden fall nicht also der über malt nee der über malt das der
über malt das ich muss das ich muss das klären fill sprite black dann wird es funktionieren
passt passt auf fill sprite tft black und dann funktioniert es pass auf ich sag's euch
jetzt jetzt geht's ich muss das einmal einmal klären excellent das ist was das könnte
ich eigentlich der anderen seite machen in dem in der anderen einfach einmal das ding
machen so mal schauen ob es jetzt geht ha ha sss warum warum blinkt das jetzt ich mein
es ist ein cooler effekt dass es blinkt mit der urzeit aber es ist nicht gewollt dass
es blinkt warum blinkt das ok wir machen mal was anders wir machen mal den timer komplett
weg wir lassen ihn so schnell neu malen wie geht also quasi alle 100 millisekunden malter
neu ich glaube ich glaube mir ist eingefallen woran das liegt ich glaube wir haben da implementierungs
mit what the fuck leute wir haben da implementierungs mäßig ein kleines problem ich weiß woran
das liegt ich weiß woran das liegt ich lasse es mal ein kommentiert wir haben da implementierungs
mäßig ein kleines problem und zwar ich glaube zumindest dass es daran liegt der
ruft hier die funktion er checkt ob hier die funktion null ist und ruft hier die funktion
auf in einem thread so und vom anderen thread aus oder vom anderen wie nennt es task ist
schöner vom anderen task setzt er das das heißt das kommt sich in die quere also sprich
manchmal manchmal guckt er hier nach die funktion ist null dann geht er hier rein dann kommt
der andere dann kommt der andere task und setzt es auf eine andere funktion und ich glaube
das liegt daran das kommt sich in die quere weil das quasi zu weist parallel zu dem wir
er schreibt warum kreischt er dann macht er macht er macht er doch der ist komplett ripp
gerade hättest du mal uml gemalt der kreischt komplett sobald ich das delay hier raus nehme
wenn ich den delay 500 rein mache dann dann kommt er sich wahrscheinlich nicht so genug
in die quere dass er kreischt allerdings hat er schon probleme ja das wird so was sein
ok soll man dann mutex mutex wie machen wir das jetzt standard mutex mutex lock ok wir
locken das jetzt einfach mal richtig low brain mäßig und und gucken ob das ob das was
bringt ok also muss man muss man static machen oder
ne ne muss ich nicht static machen also draw loop wir machen das erstmal in hier also lock
also wir machen wir bauen jetzt was ein das nicht mehr zwei tasks gleichzeitig an dieser
variabler was ändern können also während das hier läuft ist es gelockt und während
das hier läuft ist es gelockt machen das ein bisschen anders wir machen lock lock wir
locken nicht die komplette schreiboperation das wäre ein bisschen bescheuert auto f nur
die zuweisung locken wir unlock f und gleich null und an f aufrufen press f ok wo wo wo
was ist wo ist das problem es no named member lock da ist es doch was das display has no
named member lock da ist es ich habe es nicht included ich meine mal ganz ehrlich die fehlermeldung
ist absoluter shit class display has no named member lock ist total bescheuert warum sagt
er nicht fehlermeldung ist mutex not defined oder sowas oder oder not include irgendwas
ich meine er weiß doch dass mutex zur standard library gehört da kann er auch eine fehlermeldung
ausgeben did you forget include include mutex ich raffi gar nichts mehr ich habe was verwendet
was ich nicht eingebunden habe deswegen hat er gemerkt also was das jetzt macht ist folgendes
ich hoffe mal das funktioniert jetzt ja template fehler sind auch lächerlich mein lieblings
template fehler ist der hier oder mein lieblings mein lieblings fehler ist der hier und was
wifi fehlt ok warum ist wifi fehlt ah ja guck mal an leute es refrescht und blinkt nicht
mehr das wars das wars das wars das war das problem es trauert total schnell und es blinkt
nicht mehr und es kommt sich nicht mehr ins gehege das wars problem also mal zur erklärung
das hier läuft auf cpu core 1 core 1 das hier das hier läuft auf core 2 also eigentlich
mal was anders das ist core das ist core 1 und das hier ist core 0 so rum also das diese
das läuft auf einer cpu und das läuft auf der anderen cpu also cpu kern so und jetzt
ist es so dass parallel diese variable einmal neu gesetzt wird und hier werte ich sie aus
das heißt die kommen sich jetzt in die quere dadurch dass hier wird die variable neu die
variable f also besser gesagt die variable funk wird neu gesetzt aus dem eins aus von
der von dem zweiten cpu kern von cpu kern 1 wird die variable neu gesetzt und von cpu
kern 0 lese ich die variable aus und rufe die funktion da drin auf so und warum es
jetzt funktioniert ist folgendes ich sage ihm einfach ok zugriff hierauf ist nur noch
einmal gestartet ganz ganz vereinfacht gesagt ja also wirklichkeit ist es ist es das ist
dann immer lock das nennt sich mutex mutex heißt mutually exclusive lock oder so ne
mutually exclusive semaphore was heißt mutex nochmal irgendwie sowas zumindest hier wenn
ein thread hier reingeht dann setzt er das dann sagt er ok es darf kein anderer thread
mehr an dieser an dieser barriere vorbei also sprich wir haben jetzt hier einmal ein lock
gesetzt und hier einmal ein lock gesetzt also welcher thread auch immer zuerst bei diesem
lock ankommt wenn es cpu core 1 ist dann lockt er das hier und dadurch dass das hier gelockt
ist das ja das gleiche lock geht der hier nicht weiter der wartet hier bis das lock
aufgehoben ist ja ja abgehobener Vogel geht hier du kannst sagen x task create pinned
to core und hier sagst du welcher cpu kern und das hier ist die priorität priorität
ist auch eine wichtige geschichte weil tasks mit gleicher priorität context switch der
dir hin und her das scheduler also da lässt man den einen lauf mal den anderen laufen
wenn du nen task also auch wenn die blocken auch wenn die den endlosschleife drin haben
das kann der wenn du aber hier nen task mit höherer priorität reinmachst dann läuft
immer der task mit höchster priorität und wenn der nicht cpu zeit abgibt sondern endlosschleife
hat ist vorbei dann läuft nichts anderes mehr so genau und jetzt haben wir das ganze gesperrt
die schönere variante glaube ich wäre sogar sowas jetzt zu verwenden weil das ist jetzt
die c++ lock geschichte es gibt nen es gibt nen light white lock für ganz kurze sachen
im esp 32 eingebaut das nennt sich task enter task enter critical das lässt sich vielleicht
sogar ein bisschen schöner lesen und task leaf exit exit critical also sprich damit kann
man machen wir das hier mal weg machen wir es mal damit damit kann man sektionen in seinem
code markieren die immer einzeln ohne die immer einzeln ausgeführt werden ohne also
nein umgekehrt es wird garantiert dass nichts anderes ausgeführt wird auf dem gesamten
controller als das was in diesem task enter critical und zwischen task enter und task
exit liegt um genau zu sein schaltet er einfach alle interrupts ab dadurch dass alle interrupts
abgeschaltet werden geht natürlich vieles nicht mehr sowas wie sensor auslesen oder
so aber das will man dafür auch nicht machen oder ich glaube sensor auslesen die geht dann
nur hier drinnen er schaltet alle interrupts ab in dieser sektion das heißt es werden
auch keine tasks mehr geswitcht oder sonst was man muss darauf achten dass es ganz kurz
ist sonst kackt ihr das ding ab aber genau für sowas ist es so und dadurch stelle ich
jetzt sicher ok es kann nur dieses ding und niemand anderes darauf zugreifen mutex wird
unter der haube garantiert die gleiche funktion verwenden die implementierung von esp 32 beziehungsweise
für free air toss wird garantiert unter der haube das verwenden gehe ich mal von aus oder
aber nee glaube ich nicht glaube ich nicht die die verwenden den mutex der in die verwenden
den hier den den low level mutex von free air toss weil das hier weil die anderen mutex
den kannst du so lang laufen lassen wie du willst also sprich der kern da kann auch fünf
minuten hängen das ist egal ich kann ich ich kann ich fünf minuten in enter critical hängen
dann dann kackt mir das ding ab weil enter critical es läuft wirklich nichts anderes
als das also sprich auch der watchdog vom esp 32 läuft nicht mehr der esp 32 hatte
den watchdog im hintergrund laufen der guckt dass kein cpu kern hängt also wenn ich das
hier zu lang mache dann kackts ab ok probieren wirs mal aus task enter critical ich muss
mal kurz nachgucken wie man das richtig verwendet hat man muss dem nämlich glaube ich auch
noch irgendwie so ein handle übergeben esp 32 zeig mal her example please my mutex ist
ja schön ah hier excellent die nehmen wir jetzt viel überschreiben den c++ mutex mal
warum kann man eigentlich hier oben kein auto verwenden das hier nicht geht auf dem desktop
kann man das auch nicht machen ja das ist richtig dann ist es also geht gar nicht also
ich weiß nicht ob es geht und wenn es geht dann darf das definitiv der normale user nicht
man muss es so machen so wunderbar was hat er jetzt für schmerzen oh task enter ist
deprecated naja warum port enter critical na gut ok wenn er meint wenn er meint dass
task zu aussagekräftig ist dann heißt es halt port ihr verwendet die dune library was
ist das dann habe ich noch nie gehört so und wenn wir glück haben brauchen wir dieses
lock hier jetzt gar nicht mehr ich bin mal gespannt ob wir das lock hier vielleicht nicht
mehr brauchen aber wobei doch doch wahrscheinlich brauchen wir das lock noch wahrscheinlich
noch das lock brauchen wenn wir noch brauchen denke ich das zweite werden wir noch brauchen
denke ich doch doch aber wir gucken mal ob es vielleicht so funktioniert o o o o leute
oje oje monkeyes er ist schon wieder am rumspacken ok wir machen hier auch noch ein lock drüber
rum äh wann verwendet man bei der deklaration ein underscore als notation das ist bei mir
eine angewohnheit ich verwende das für private klassen variablen also quasi für alles was
private ist underscore das macht man den c++ wahrscheinlich nicht so oh ach man warum geht
das jetzt nicht warum was ist das problem das war ich hab mir das theoretisch so gut
überlegt und jetzt geht es nicht auf wir machen big brain leute wir machen pass mal
auf pass mal auf das habe ich mir jetzt nicht spontan ausgedacht das hatte ich nämlich
schon mal dass denn dazu war dass denn dass denn die zuweisung ich machen wollte was line
64 o o o o oje moment nein nein nein ah exit nicht zweimal enter habe ich hier oben richtig
gemacht ja siehst du fail chat mal wieder to to smart excellent chat mal gucken ob es
jetzt funktioniert aber das hatte ich schon mal dass die zuweisung nicht ging aber aber
swap hat funktioniert oder sieht besser aus das sieht besser aus aha es funktioniert
geht nice excellent sehr schön ja das gefällt mir jetzt richtig gut das lässt sich auch
richtig gut verwenden was mich was ich mich ja frage ist was ist der unterschied zwischen
dem und dem gibt es da einen unterschied function swap function assign macht es irgendeinen
unterschied weil ich hatte schon mal dass das nicht funktioniert aber das hier ging
vielleicht ich swap atomar nein ist es nicht das ist c++ natürlich ist es überhaupt nicht
atomic atomic ist nur standard passbar auf c++ lull atomic exchange ist atomar ah yes
es gibt dann auch um die sache noch komplizierter zu machen es gibt auch noch standard swap
passbar den c++ leuten schief läuft ich weiß es nicht gut also funktioniert ich bin begeistert
das heißt vielleicht haben wir glück unser update geht jetzt auch wieder call update
common auf common bra update postchamp ha oh ne ha es geht exzellent
so einfach ist es mit dem try catch auf dem esp 32 auch nicht du kannst nicht alles ketschen
zum beispiel memory fehler und du kannst nicht ketschen es funktioniert hütsch porgores
ich bin begeistert sehr sehr nice so was wir jetzt noch machen ist finish callback display
auf und im start callback setzen wir jetzt noch moment wir machen wir machen noch einen
anderen exzellent smart move nämlich wir machen noch funktionen für void string kippt
er zurück gen progress gen progress oder fack wie nenne ich das ding gen progress bar progress
übergeben return tmp sehr schön weil was wir jetzt machen können ist sagen gen progress
bar im progress übergeben und wir können dadurch dass wir das jetzt in eine funktion
gepackt haben können wir es nämlich an anderer stelle auch noch mal verwenden vielleicht
machen wir das hier noch dabei zumindest meine idee ist dass ich das beim start callback auch
noch mal verwende und es da halt eben auf null setze progress ist null das heißt wenn
er startet startet er auch mit null prozent und nicht mit vier prozent aber liegt das
jetzt nicht speicher wieso sollte speicher liegen jetzt hier also vielleicht habe ich
was übersehen kann schon sein wo liegt das speicher ok ok achtung was warum wechselt
er immer die farben what the hell was ist da los kann mir das mal irgendjemand schlüssig
erklären warum der immer die farben wechselt zwischendurch ich verstehe es nicht weil
jetzt haben wir die probleme nicht was ist mit den farben los warum war es was spackt
er damit den farben wir machen mal ein update wenn wir update jetzt gucken wir mal zu jetzt
gucken wir mal zu aber mit null prozent anfängt ja wohl das ist richtig gut das
richtig nice exzellent ist das exzellent ist das nicht schön ist das nicht schön das ist
so nice ich habe ich verklickt der pedo bär hat damit nichts zu tun was soll das werden also
aktuell macht das firmware update übers wlan und zeigt eine progress bar an wie lang das
firmware update noch braucht wenn ich das habe kann ich was sinnvolles mit dem board machen
ist das nice aber was hat er mit dem was hat er für schmerzen mit der color warum muss ich die
manchmal in wörter setzen und manchmal nicht das ergibt doch überhaupt keinen sinn da
in den flack was ich noch setzen muss was da was da rumspackt machen das anders setzen set wir machen set swap setzen wir hier im display das initialisiert
ja okay also was der für problem ist ist ein bug in der display library oder was ist das was was
macht er dafür dinger vielleicht vor dem create sprite setzen gute gute idee vielleicht spackt das
sonst rum ja ja kann sein also ich habe wirklich keine ahnung was der für probleme hat gerade mit
mit der mit der farbe so undurchsichtig irgendwie was warum okay leute ich ziehe mal strom raus
mach strom rein ich traue der sache nicht okay der hat irgendwelche probleme gehabt irgendwelche
probleme fragt mich nicht welche irgendwas wurden reset auf jeden fall hilft so richtig
die echte reset soll ich reset jetzt mal so was was warum warum ist das nach einem reset
hat was was verstehe nicht also wirklich das das verstehe ich absolut gar nicht es ist okay nachdem
ich das erste mal starte und dann war es gibt doch überhaupt kein sinn es ist auf jeden fall
interessantes problem ja ich habe wirklich absolut keinen platzen schimmer liegt das an
display on set brightness 50 ne das kann er nicht daran liegen er muss set display on machen sonst
gibt es jetzt display nicht an ja set backlight ist oft habe ich hier irgendwelche sachen die mit
dem er in die quere kommt macht das array mal konst was welches welches what the fuck warum
ist die farbe anders das welches array soll ich ich glaube mit dem array mit was wie wo welches
array mit dem da oben ich muss schon bisschen genauer ich weiß nicht welches so was wo welche
datei an welcher stelle das image das hier das kann damit nichts zu tun haben ja die grafik ist
konstricht was hat er für schmerzen also ich bin jetzt wirklich echt ratlos
punch set qq ne keine ahnung also vielleicht musste straße straße und straßenname mal ein
bisschen vertauschen ich weiß nicht ob die der ami schreibweise deutsche schreibweise haben ok
ich habe wirklich keine ahnung was der für schmerzen warum warum warum ist das aber warum
ist es nach dem neustart weg was macht er dann mit dem eier ja bild was macht dann mit dem
eier ja bild set swap bei uns wir malen mal eier ja eier ja ja ja ob es dann richtig was
ach so int ja ok keine ahnung unter das ist jetzt wieder echt so ein problem das
mir absolut nicht einleuchtet jetzt ist wieder ok ja ja fix alles ok restart restart
moment warum geht das jetzt ich bin verwirrt was ist der unterschied was ist der unterschied
zwischen trauer eier ja und trauer welkommen load font fill sprite ich fülle das sprite nicht
swap beides true push image set text color satin trostring technik die begeistert ja vielleicht
was mit der bild datei mit der bild datei kann es nicht sein weil der macht es ja mal so und mal
so und die bild daten sind immer exakt die gleichen da ist garantiert kein unterschied
das ist immer das gleiche so ok da machen wir jetzt statt straw eier ja trauer welcome
counter hat es vielleicht was mit der urzeit zu tun ihre anzeige dass es darum spakt so also
jetzt sind beide methoden exakt gleich nur dass das mit eier ja funktioniert aber mit dem anderen
image nicht heute das leuchtet mir nicht ein was war denn jetzt das problem dass ich hier
swap beides noch mal setzen muss aber das habe ich doch schon mal gesetzt warum geht es denn
jetzt das ist mir zu hoch ok ok es funktioniert message und string count ja das eine ist ein int
und das andere ist aber jetzt geht ja trauer welkommen auch ok wir machen hier aber noch
wir machen wir nicht machen wir nicht ich lasse jetzt aber trauer ja auch mal die urzeit anzeigen
und dann gucken wir mal string message ok also helper get time so einmal trauer jetzt
haben wir es mit trauer welkommen noch mal gucken ob es jetzt wieder rumspackt vielleicht
war auch dass ich vielleicht war auch das problem dass ich das bild jedes mal gesettet
hat mit black wobei das eigentlich ok ist vielleicht muss ich vielleicht muss ich das
nur in alles in der richtigen reinfolge irgendwie machen könnte das sein dass das rumspackt
wenn ich das nee nee ok jetzt alles gut so und jetzt dass ich musste ich musste da aus
irgendwelchen gründen noch mal die byte oder irgendwie setzen was auch immer so und weil
jetzt waren wir hier noch mal hinten dran und jetzt geht es wahrscheinlich immer noch
und ich habe legit keine ahnung woran es liegt aber es scheint zu funktionieren hoffe
ich jetzt hoffe jetzt nicht dass ich das gebetet habe weil ich so sicher bin dass es funktioniert
auf hey es riecht gut aus ja ok ok wieder so ein schöner fehler absolut nichts geändert
großartig aber jetzt funktioniert es auf einmal alles klar restart und geht es immer noch
restart jawoll geht immer noch ok keine ahnung was das für man man weiß es nicht man man
weiß es nicht gut wunderbar sehr schön hat funktioniert jetzt gucken wir uns noch mal
noch eine sache und wir haben noch ein bisschen zeit irgendeine funktion ändert implizit
swaps bytes kann durchaus sein ich meine ich habe es hier drinnen hier drinnen mache ich
jetzt noch mal raus ich meine ich setze es hier explizit aber ich mache es jetzt noch
mal raus der wichtige ist dass ich es mache bevor ich die bilder male weil ich glaube
auf was anderes hat es eh keinen einfluss als auf die bilder für push image es gilt
was hat das eine mit dem anderen zu tun das wird mir langsam echt so blöd was hat das
eine da jetzt mit dem anderen zu tun ok ok wisst ihr was machen wir kurz das überschreiben
aus aber das überschreiben muss ich hin machen dass es hier richtig richtig funktioniert
glaube ich habe was das liegt an dem film black was hat das mit dem film black zu tun
was hat das mit dem film black zu tun ok leute ich ich verstehe es nicht wir halten uns
da jetzt nicht weiter dran auf ich checke es wirklich absolut nicht ich meine egal wir
lassen es jetzt erstmal so was willst du machen ja was das es funktioniert jetzt das hat mich
jetzt so verwirrt das anpassen hier mit den zahlen funktioniert aber auch noch alles gut
kann man denn jetzt abwechselnd ja ja und und welkommen mal die lei da war mal ok wir machen
mal kein delay oder dass da auch gott war ja ja das sollte jetzt im hundert millisekunden
takt abwechseln ne funktioniert gar nicht funktioniert gar nicht weil die hundert millisekunden
nicht passen ich muss da ich muss ich muss da schon in den delay dazwischen machen das
ist z plus plus leider ist das z plus plus 500 mal gucken was der jetzt macht der kackt
jetzt voll ab auch ne funktioniert ja halbwegs random top notch animation hier
ok wunderbar damit wisst ihr was leute aber mich fuckt das immer noch übelst
ab dass das hier was damit zu tun hat dass er das hier push wenn ich filz sprite black
sage und das verstehe ich nicht filz sprite tft was hat das damit zu tun warum spackt
er darum das leuchtet überhaupt nicht ein aber wisst ihr was scheiß drauf lasst uns
jetzt erstmal so wunderbar also jetzt habe ich voll den faden verloren durch die ganze
scheiß was wollte ich eigentlich machen also wir haben es jetzt geschafft dass der keine
probleme mehr hat multithreader zuzugreifen auf die auf das display alles wunderbar synchronisiert
und ich glaube das update funktioniert hoffentlich auch noch schauen wir mal update sollte jetzt
starten gucken wir mal zu update übers wlan rüber pushen ja das funktioniert auch wunderbar
moment warum steht da null oh es ist denn weil er nicht refreshed da muss das da muss
das neu painten sonst spackt rum ja perfekt also ich brauche den ich brauche da drinnen
allen ernst ich brauche hier dieses filz sprite black und warum mag das nicht kannst
du den so schon ja theoretisch schon aber das ist mir jetzt so doof ich werde das jetzt
einfach ignorieren und noch was anderes machen nämlich gucken wie ich eine html seite ausliefern
kann über den über den webserver der eingebaut ist so eine mini html seite dass man auch
firmen update über web interface machen kann ok aus irgendwelchen gründen geht es jetzt
wieder mal zur abwechslung aber er malt kein eierjahr mehr ist mir egal ich mache ein update
ob update aha jetzt funktioniert gut ich lasse es jetzt so wir probieren es jetzt mit dem
webserver aus wurscht ignore ignore ignore also ich wollte mir angucken wie man hier
noch eine index html seite ausliefern kann was ich mir dazu überlegt habe ist folgendes
wir gehen mal hin wo wir das ganze registrieren sagen wir hier resource note index also wir
liefern jetzt leere html seite aus oder wir liefern eine html seite aus aber hier keine
ahnung touch index html und da machen wir ein ganz normales html 5 gerüst rein ohne
irgendwas das dashboard das update braucht man irgendwas von dem anderen müll hier oder
das braucht man wahrscheinlich auch nicht was macht das da überhaupt macht das irgendwas
sinnvolles was soll die platine mal werden also für die habe ich ehrlich gesagt keinen
genauen noch keinen genauen anwendungszweck ich war am überlegen ob ich das nicht generell
diese sorte boards so als default board für neue projekte nehmen und bin gerade ein bisschen
am testen was man damit alles machen kann und wie man das display für was man das display
sinnlos sinnvoll verwenden kann eventuell mache ich das als ablöse für meine klimaanlagen
steuerungs ding also sprich als ablösung für das da aktuell habe ich mir so ein teil hier
gebastelt das ist noch was anderes mit display vielleicht nehme ich das hier mit dem farb
display dafür für steuerung für die klimaanlage mal gucken ich weiß ja nicht genau aktuell
wollte ich einfach mal schauen wie man wlan updates machen kann mit progress anzeigen
auf dem bildschirm das funktioniert ja mittlerweile ausgesprochen gut jetzt gucken wir mal wie
man eine index html seite ausliefern kann dass man vielleicht auch so ein mini dashboard
ausliefern kann dass man nicht immer firmware update über curl pushen muss checkt ja keiner
so gut chat index html dann gehen wir in den update rein sagen slash get handle handle
keine ahnung handle index default schneller finde dann sagen wir hier register default
note dass er quasi auf jede url die ich gehe die nicht eines hiervon ist das muss man als
letztes registren er mich auf die index seite weiterleitet cpp monka s cpp deals batman
das ist eine gute idee gute idee und weil ich das wahrscheinlich eher triggern würde
von meiner heim automatisierung über einen web aufruf so nach dem motto jetzt ist nacht
und dann geht das ganze haus in nach modus unter anderem auch dort die display helligkeit
aber das kann man hier in den webserver noch einbauen so also hendl update hendl hendl was
was ich index so jetzt müssen wir bloß noch hendl index einbauen wo sind wir index ja
da nicht restart sondern index und dann copy pasten wir das ganze mal hier davon so und
jetzt ist meine idee dass ich die index html seite aus dem flash speicher ausliefer also
dass man die index html seite gar nicht irgendwie hier als als char array blub html gleich irgendwas
sondern dass er das aus dem pfeilsystem ausliest und als antwort also vom pfeilsystem ausliest
morgen habe ich einen da schreibt der haufen aus manny sagt morgen habe ich ein reihungstest
fürs informatik studium was ist eine reihungstest sowas wie aufnahmeprüfung oder sowas
ja ok reihungstest klingt nach klingt nach schweiz oder so so hendl index muss das ganze
heißen so also jetzt öffnen wir eine datei aber spiffs open und zwar open wir index html
im read mode file so dann oh jetzt muss ich mal kurz überlegen dann müssen wir den kram
ich hab den h auf dem bildschirm also dann müssen wir die datei öffnen irgendwie einlesen
und gleichermaßen während wir einlesen die zurückschreiben weil komplette datei einlesen
in ram kann ich nicht das ding hat noch frag mich nicht 80 kilobyte ram frei oder so das
ist ja da komme ich da komme ich nicht weit also quasi dass wir sagen dass wir sagen weil
irgendwie irgendwie einlesen das ganze file read read bites dann brauchen wir den buffer
buffer aus 250 bytes das reicht dann lesen wir ein char buffer achso das ding was wir
irgendwie nennen ne warte mal wie ging das buffer ist ja c so ging das so und dann lesen
wir ein 256 bytes und wir lesen so lang ein bis read bites was gibt denn read bites zurück
also die die gelesen was mache ich denn hier die gelesene anzahl ja aber was gibt es zurück
wenn es nichts mehr zu lesen gibt minus eins oder größer null größer null wir machen
größer null also solange solange man sachen lesen kann aus der datei lesen wir und schreiben
die antwort in die response right buffer 256 bytes ne moment wir machen nicht immer 256
bytes sondern so viel wie ich gelesen habe schreiben wir da rein moment wie ich gelesen
das kann man doch nicht so machen oder das kann man doch nicht so machen kann man kann
man sowas machen ne das geht nicht oder size das das geht nicht oder geht sowas ist das
ist das valid c++ das kompiliert aber macht es auch das was ich will keine ahnung size
also read in the box wenn das funktioniert dann müsste doch eigentlich direkt anlegen
in der schleife auch gehen oder oder nicht was hatte hier was was what the fuck hat er
schon schmerzen ach der will das als uint acht ok dann müssen wir das ganze carsten
uint ist ja eh alles der gleiche schmodder na ob das jetzt klappt da bin ich aber gespannt
darf man sowas hier machen das sieht das sieht übelst kaputt aus aber anscheinend zu funktionieren
machen wir mal ne print print ausgabe handle index achso und was wir auch noch machen sollten
ist vielleicht sowas setzen wie response header und dann sowas setzen wie content type content
type ist text ist es text plane oder ist es ne ist es text html na so content type so mal
hochladen muss die datei noch hochladen die index hat dem dann muss man hochladen upload
upload achja da er lädt hoch normalerweise spackt er da immer rum da bin ich ja mal gespannt
ob er das jetzt macht. Also, Curl, nicht Restart, sondern einfach nur Index. Ist er neu gestartet?
Ah, es ist wieder gelb, es ist wieder gelb. Warum ist es wieder gelb? Wir ignorieren das
jetzt. Mir fällt da bestimmt noch die Lösung für ein. Genau, rufen wir mal die Seite ab.
Scheint nicht so funktioniert zu haben mit der Webseite. Warum hat es mit der
Seite nicht funktioniert? Er ruft das Richtige auf, aber eine Webseite kommt da nicht zurück.
Und warum nicht? Handle Index. Spiffs Open Index. Index. IP liegt. Bonkers, schon wieder.
Das müsste doch jetzt eigentlich gehen. Ich wette mit euch mein Konstrukt hier funktioniert nicht.
In size steht das Ergebnis drinnen von dem Vergleich. Achtung, Big Brain Logik. Geht sowas?
Okay, genug, genug gewurstet. Machen wir so. Dann sagen wir hier File Available. Das gibt es
nämlich auch noch. Solange File Available ist, machen wir weiter. Upload. Aber da gibt es
bestimmt irgendetwas, wo man C++ in while. Nein, ich will keine Vorschleife. Gehst du fort,
Vorschleife ist viel zu mainstream. Vorschleife. Ich benutze keine Vorschleifen. Ich benutze nur
if-Schleifen. So, Webseite abrufen. Ah, guck mal, da ist die Webseite. Exzellent.
Und Webseite geht es. Q-Chain, die Webseite funktioniert. Guckt euch an, da ist die Webseite,
die ich vom ESP ausliefer. Aber die Ladezeiten sind halt der Horror. Die Ladezeiten sind hardcore
lang. Wie konnte man den Kram noch mal nach unten konfigurieren? Guckt euch mal die Ladezeiten an.
Aber HTTPS auf so einem Ding ist lahm. Hat das Ding nicht sogar ein bisschen Hardware drauf für
IS? Guckt mal hier. 15 Sekunden bis die Seite da ist. Okay, aus dem Cache ist schneller. Aus dem Cache
dauert es nur 180, also nur 2 Sekunden. Okay, wenn es der ESP im Cache hat, sind es auch noch
2 Sekunden. Geht doch eigentlich. 2 Sekunden ist doch eigentlich vollkommen okay. Nein,
nicht 0,2. 2 Sekunden. 2000 Millisekunden sind 2 Sekunden. Ja, das geht doch eigentlich. Ist
doch in Ordnung. Aber am Firefox auf. Ja, ja. Auf. Das geht doch voll klar. Das geht voll klar für
die Seite. Komm mal 3 Sekunden für so ein Dashboard. Gut, das wird noch ein bisschen länger laden,
wenn die Seite länger wird. Aber das ist doch vollkommen in Ordnung. Das meiste davon ist
eh. Der macht 2 Sekunden HTTPS und 0,01 Sekunden ausliefern. Ja, das geht voll klar. Machen wir
mal ein bisschen längere. Kann man die Sache, kann man die auch gezippen, die Seite? Und ich
habe noch eine andere Idee. Kann ich den SSH-Key nicht auf Spiffs legen? Wie generell? Okay,
aber das, das probieren wir jetzt mal. Wir probieren auch die 2 Sachen, weil wir haben
noch eine halbe Stunde Zeit. Also. Jetzt habe ich schon wieder, ich bin low-brain. Das ist
genau gezippt. Nee, gezippt macht es nicht langsamer, glaube ich nicht, weil das Entpacken
passiert ja rein auf Browser-Seite. Also sprich, mein ESP selbst muss sogar weniger machen,
weil es weniger auslesen muss. Okay, wir machen die Seite jetzt mal ein bisschen länger,
dass es ein bisschen was zu tun hat. Die Frage ist, was da Zeit in Anspruch nimmt. Also ich denke,
der hatte der TLS Handshake und das ganze Zeug nimmt Zeit in Anspruch. ESP32, Hardware, TLS. Hat er
sowas? Wolf-SSL. Was ist Wolf-SSL? Die haben irgendeine Art von Hardware. Acceleration.
Wolf-SSL. Okay. Der Benchmark sieht hart nach Open SSL aus. Ich guck mal kurz hier bei dem,
übrigens die Library wollte ich ja auch noch einbinden. ESP32 HTPS. Was der zum Thema
Acceleration sagt. Hat er übrigens auf mein Kommentar im Pull-Request geantwortet? Nope.
Acceleration 0. Ja. Das wäre jetzt noch interessant. Warum überhaupt HTPS? Naja,
weil man sich dann viel weniger Gedanken machen muss. Letztendlich ist es daheim im WLAN und es
ist eh ziemlich irrelevant. Ja, wenn du das sagst, würde ich dir recht geben. Aber es hat den Vorteil,
die Firma wird verschlüsselt übertragen, falls man da irgendwie keinen Bock hat,
irgendwas im Klartext reinschreibt. Und noch viel wichtiger, mal angenommen,
man macht eine Passwort-Authentifizierung davor, dann werden auch alle Passwörter automatisch
verschlüsselt übertragen. Man bräuchte es nicht. Also eine andere Variante wäre zum Beispiel, die
Firmware irgendwie zu signen und dann zu gucken, ob die Signatur stimmt oder sowas,
nach dem Übertragen. Und das Ganze halt über HTTP zu übertragen, nicht über HTTPS. Aber
ich finde es poggers, dass man das, dass man HTTPS machen kann. Encryption. Ich finde es
interessant, dass die sowas haben überhaupt. Interessante Geschichte. Okay, also das mit
Gzip probieren wir jetzt noch aus. Ja, wenn du das Passwort Kleinzeit hascht. Ja gut, das kannst du
machen. Du kannst Passwort Kleinzeit haschen. Dann würdest du auf dem Server einfach nur
überprüfen, ob das stimmt. Aber dann würde es ja reichen, wenn jemand den Hash abgreift,
weil er sich mit dem Hash authentifizieren konnte. By the way, in ICQ war das so früher. ICQ wollte
das Benutzerspasswort schützen und hat das Passwort gehasht beim Client abgelegt,
ohne das Passwort, ohne alles und hat sich mit dem Hash authentifiziert gegen den Server. Also sprich,
wenn jemand den Hash mitgelesen hat, konnte er sich damit authentifizieren bei ICQ. Save ging
abhören, wenn der Hash quasi das Passwort ist zum Freischalten, dann nicht. Hast du das,
äh, hast du vor, das NVIDIA Event zu stüfen? Wann ist denn das? Okay, ich Gzippe das mal kurz.
Gzippe, Index. Komm mal, jetzt sind es nur noch 156 Bytes. 1.9., das schreibe ich mir mal auf.
Ups. Hallo. Schreibe ich mir mal auf. Äh, Events. Also 1.9., 18 Uhr NVIDIA. Falls man da streamen
darf, mal gucken. Nicht, dass die den Apple machen hier. Okay. So, wenn wir Gzippe ausliefern
wollen, dann müssten wir noch was anderes machen. Dann müssten wir sagen, Set header,
Content encoding ist Gzippe. Gzippe. Und jetzt liefern wir nicht Index.html aus,
sondern Index.html.gz. Graz. Und jetzt uploaden wir das nochmal. Äh, so. Gibt Gerüchte,
dass die RTX 3090 ein Triple-Slot-Design wird. Ja, immer her damit. Ich brauche neue Hardware.
Meinetwegen können die ein Acht-Slot-Design machen, wenn das ordentlich Wumms hat. Dann
lohnt es sich endlich mal, dass ich immer die fetten Fractal-Design-Gehäuse kaufe.
Oder ein eigenes Rack für die Grafikkarte. Einfach 26 HE Grafikkarte. Easy. 12, nee,
ich habe nur 12 HE. 12 HE Grafikkarte. Räume ich extra meinen Rack für leer. So, jetzt
sollte der die Gzippe-Index ausliefern und mal gucken, wie schnell das ist. Exzellent.
Exzellent. Exzellent. Jetzt dreht er langsam durch hier. So. Und jetzt ist es wieder blau.
Das macht mich fertig. Das, das Ding. Das macht mich legit fertig.
Das könnte sein. Ich habe mir nämlich mal ein Images-File angeguckt gerade. Also ein
Images-File, was ich hier... Sag mal, bin ich jetzt lauter? Nee, oder? Nee. Ich glaube,
ich höre mich einfach nur lauter an. Oder habe ich das Mikrofon jetzt besser platziert?
Nee, es ist genauso. Es ist immer noch genau das gleiche. Alles gut. Zwar haben die anderen
das da oben drin stehen in ihrer... In ihrem Header noch. Ob das da mit irgendwas zu tun
hat? Bug-Fix für die Farbe. Eine Kamera, mit der du automatisierst, die Farbe erkennst
und wenn es nicht blau ist, dann Repo, solange bis es blau wird. Exzellent-Idee. Weil das,
das trifft ja hier überhaupt nicht zu. Ich würde wegmachen. Gut, also schauen wir mal,
was es dir für eine Website ausgibt. Curl. Ob da jetzt was Geh-Zipp, das rauskommt? Kommt
da... Alter, kommt da was Geh-Zipp, das raus? Ja, ja. Gun-Zipp. Oh, oh, oh, abbrechen, abbrechen.
Ah, ganz, ganz. Ah, funktioniert. Q-Chat. Leute, habt ihr das gesehen da? Bam. Also,
funktioniert. Das kommt in Geh-Zipp raus und man kann es entpacken. Sehr schön. Exzellent-Exzellent.
Gut. Machen wir das mal hier. Ja, ja, ich weiß. Proceed. Das braucht jetzt ein bisschen,
bis es ausgeliefert hat. Watt? Ah, da ist es. Fünf, fünf wird doch okay. Das ist doch...
Guck mal, jetzt geht das Ganze auch viel schneller, weil die Datei kleiner ist. Was du streamst
täglich... Wer sagt denn das? Q-Chat, Q-Chat, Q-Chat. So, eine Sache, probieren wir jetzt
nochmal, dass sich der SSH-Key nicht immer ändert. Tatsächlich, ja. Aber, aber noch
eine halbe Stunde oder so. Wie generiere ich denn mir mit OpenSSL den Key dafür? Da müssen
wir mal gucken. Weil aktuell ist es ja so, ich zeig's euch mal, dass der bei jedem Reboot
ein neues Self-Sign-Zertifikat generiert. Das ist kein Problem. Ja, also das ist jetzt
nicht, dass das irgendwie großartig problematisch wäre, dass der sich ein eigenes Zertifikat
generiert. Aber zum Beispiel mein Browser spackt dabei ein bisschen rum. Zum Beispiel
Firefox mag das nicht, wenn man da drauf ist auf der Seite. Und quasi in der gleichen
Session sich der Key mehrfach ändert. Das mag Firefox nicht. Dann sagt Firefox, oh
nee, ich zeig die Seite nicht an. Guck, so was da. Und man kann dann auch nicht nochmal
sagen, okay. Deswegen wäre cool, wenn man vielleicht den Key noch laden könnte vom
Filesystem. Das heißt, ich generiere jetzt mal ein SSL-Zertifikat mit OpenSSL-Commandos
sind...Self...OpenSSL-Commandos sind, okay. You can do that in one command. Okay. Also,
RSA 4096 ist ein bisschen viel. Ach so, gültig. Gültig für immer. Mal 100. Gültig für 36.000
Tage. Exzellent. Muss ich meine Webseite, komplette Webseite, gzipen und jede einzelne?
Gar nicht. Du musst gar nichts gzippen. Ich hab mal 100 im Rechner gemacht, ja. Jetzt
wo du es sagst. Es ist jetzt die Frage. Es ist jetzt die Frage. Oi? Oder Big Brain? Jetzt
ist es die Frage. Moment, wie macht man das ohne Passphrase? Ah nee. Wie macht man das
ohne Passphrase? Wobei das liegt. Without Passphrase. Nee, leeres Passwort ging nicht. Da hat er
noch gemeckert. You must type 1-1024. Ach so, man kann auch gleich Zert nehmen. Nee,
man muss gar nicht. Moment. Ach so, das ist weil ich hier Key und so in einem mach. Moment.
Open Messers L-Commandos, Alter. Moment. Ich bin, ich bin verwirrt. Ich bin verwirrt.
Das soll. Okay, country.de. Das ist egal. Egal. KQ. Server FQDM. Das ist doch. Letztendlich
ist egal. So, kann der Zertifikate von der Disk? Ja, mach's gut. Danke, Niko. Kann man
hier irgendwie Zerts laden? What? Okay, das gucken wir uns mal auf der Webseite von dem
Dude an. Scheint nicht so einfach zu sein, aber einfach mal irgendwelche Keys zu generieren.
Open Messers L. Open Messers L. Da muss es doch hier irgendwie ein Beispiel geben, wie
man Open Messers L Zerts macht, die das Ding frisst. Ja, Create Zert. Perfekt. Man braucht
ein extra Script für Sachen, die zwei Commandos und gut ist. Docs. What? Der File. Kann man
das vielleicht auch mal im Klartext sich irgendwie anzeigen lassen? Oder wo gibt's denn die
Docs dafür überhaupt? Docs. Moin. Ich versuche mir gerade ein Self-Signed SSL Zertifikat
zu generieren, was den Gramm, was der Web-Server hier checkt. Oh, wie lange sind wir schon
am Start? Fuck, schon drei Stunden zehn wieder. Alter. Okay, dann mache ich das halt mit seinem
komischen Skript hier. Geht auch. To see data header. Moment, ich will keinen, ich will
keinen see header. Will ich gar nicht. Ich will. Ich will das, ich will, ich will, ich
will das einlesen vom File System. Der will anscheinend der Files oder sowas. Hab ich
noch nie, hab ich noch nie gesehen und ich weiß gar nicht, was der Files überhaupt
und sind. Okay. Examplecker. Ich lade jetzt mal diesen komischen hier runter. Gehen wir
auf Master. Wir sind schon angemacht. Wer schreibt, dass er denn der File will? Ja.
Lass da runterladen. Zack. Ciamod plus X. Create Zert. Zert. So, also was hat er jetzt
für was? Make sure. Da hier. Da sind die der Files. Example key der und example Zert
der. Das lesen wir jetzt nämlich vom File System ein, weil das viel nicer ist. Und
was steht da drinnen? Ja, binary geschwobelt. Ach, kann das sein, dass das irgendein binary
Format ist? Dieses der File. Painer ab. Abonniert Twitch Prime. Dankeschön. Huge Subscription.
Big Brain Move. So, die Header Files verwenden wir, also wir verwenden die Header Dateien
und nicht die Header Files, weil ich will den Kram nicht. Ich hab nämlich kein Bock,
dass mein Sketch unnütz viel Zeug verbrät, ne? Also, copy. Example key. Example Dings
nach, äh, wie heißt das Projekt? Display. Data. Exzellent. So, da ist es. Also wir haben
einen Example Zert Punkt der. Okay, den anderen Krampel kann ich löschen. Muss nur gucken,
dass es nicht. Das kann ich auch löschen. Mein Index lass ich da. So, den ganzen Kram
mal uploaden. Das ist so die letzte Amtshandlung für heute dann. Gucken, ob das funktioniert.
Ne, der will es binary haben. Okay, probieren wir mal aus. Also, wir müssen kein neues
Zertifikat generieren. Wir können das so machen. Wir hatten doch hier irgendwo ein
Beispiel gerade. Und jetzt blöd, hab ich wieder zugemacht. Ja, noch hier ein Beispiel mit
OpenSSL. Moment, wo hab ich's denn eben gefunden? Mit dem der-File, wo hab ich's denn eben gefunden?
Zert. Hier. Da ist es doch. Das, das wollen wir haben. So. SSL Zert. So. Zert. Passt.
Wir generieren ja, wir generieren ja kein neues. Wir weisen das hier zu. So. Also. Der Format
Zertifikat Länge. Gut, da müssen wir den Kram einlesen vom File System. Spiffs. Open.
Open File. So. Wir haben hier einmal das File. Example. Example. CRT Punkt der. Read. Kann
man, kann man direkt? Also, ja. Open. Read. Read. Read. Komplett, komplett einlesen.
So, das ist das Zert. Text. Und als nächstes haben wir dann Example Key Punkt der. Moment,
muss man, muss man das clausen? Muss man das, muss man das irgendwie clausen? Close. Gibt
das so was wie using in C++? Eher anscheinend nicht. Spiffs. Spiffs. Open. Muss man das
clausen, die Datei? Oder claust es automatisch, wenn es aus dem Scope geht? Okay, man muss
das clausen. Ah gut. FS. Dann. Zert. Read. Und Close. So. FS. Open. Ich bin mal gespannt,
ob das funktioniert. Oh fuck, ich hab eben was vergessen. Ah. What the fuck. Ich hab,
ich hab Simikolons vergessen. Oder Simikola, wie die coolen Leute sagen. Ich sag Simikolons.
So, also das da, jetzt haben wir den Key. Die Musik übelst laut gerade. Nö. GC404.
Das muss ja nicht mal ein GC sein, in Rust kriegen sie das ja auch hin, wenn das Auto
aus dem Scope geht. Also das automatisch macht. So. Open. Jetzt haben wir so was wie Auto Key.
FS. Read. String. So. Und dann sagen wir FS. Close. So, jetzt haben wir die Sachen
hier eingelesen. Klappt auch. Zert. Der. Ist das da. Zert. Length ist Zert. Length.
Key. Und Key. Length. Jetzt bin ich ja mal echt gespannt, ob der Kram funktioniert.
Ok. Was, was ist das für ein Problem? Ah. Es muss als Oldschool C String sein. Weil.
Nein. Ok. Was? Äh. Ok. Äh, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, was?
Was willst du von mir? Ok. Das ist alles kein Problem. Machen wir easy. Wir casten
einfach. Was hat er jetzt verschmerzt? Ach, New. New. So. Jetzt. Jetzt bin ich ja mal
gespannt, ob der das Zertifikat lesen kann. Ich wäre, ich wäre jetzt sehr verwundert,
ob das funktioniert. Das ist garantiert in irgendeinem falschen Format. Es kann auch
sein, dass wir es beinahe es kann übrigens sein, dass wir es beinahe lesen müssen. Wahrscheinlich
müssen wir es beinahe binary lesen, gehe ich mal von aus. Wahrscheinlich müssen wir es
beinahe lesen. Stats abrufen. Oh. Fail to connect. Connection refused. Weil. Sagt er
nicht. Connection refused. Ok. Der mag das Zertifikat nicht, Leute. Der hat was gegen
das Zertifikat. Oh. Wobei. Ist die ist die IP überhaupt richtig gewesen? Habt ihr nachgeschaut,
was für eine IP gekriegt habe? Aber Connection refused. Das klingt schon irgendwie ein bisschen.
Ja. Read by denke ich auch. Zert Setup failed. Ok. Dann was anderes. Read by. Read by. Aber
vor allem, woher weiß der denn, wann fertig ist? Gar nicht, ne? Das ist aber eklig. Warum
kann ich das nicht alles in einem? Ach Gott. Ok. Also. Also. Dann. Buffer. Bytes. Keine
Ahnung. Buffer 1. Mir fällt langsam echt nichts mehr ein. FS. Länge. Size. Size. Darf
man sowas hier machen überhaupt? Ist sowas erlaubt? Sowas legit? Ah Moment. Vielleicht
um die Klammer zu machen. Ok. Das erlaubt. Buffer. Ok. Das erlaubt. Ok. Also. Buffer
1. Länge. FS. Size. Eieieieiei. Und jetzt? Geht das jetzt? Nein. Warum? Weil Byte und
Char nicht zusammen passen. Warum ist Read Bytes? Warum kommt dann Char raus? Ich meine,
es sind 8 Bits allesamt, aber trotzdem. 22 Jewel. Ja, passt. Ich hab morgen ja eh frei.
Nächste. Also. Weiter. Buffer 2. Die Size muss ich mir beideweise auch noch speichern,
das wird das nix. Also. CRT. CRT. Size. FS. Size. Mein Gott, das ist was komplexierend.
CRT. Size. So. Key. Auto. Key. Size. Jetzt aber. Jetzt aber. Ha? Bild. Nein. Doch.
Key. Size. Und jetzt brauchen wir hier. Assert. Und hier den Key. Haieieiei. Was?
Was hat denn jetzt schon wieder für Schmerzen? Mein Buffer ist. Ach. Moment, da hab ich es
falsch rumgemacht. Habe ich es falsch rumgemacht? Was? Alter, was willst du von mir? C++ Zeug.
Was? Expected? Hab ich ein Semikolon irgendwo vergessen? Expected before start. Wo hab ich
was vergessen? Ah. Okay. Und jetzt merkt er da, dass ich casten muss. Und übrigens gebe
ich hier auch Mist an. Totaler Blödsinn, was ich hier. Was ich hier angebe. Ich muss
Buffer 1 angeben und, und, und. Buffer 2. Und den Mist hier kann ich überhaupt wegschmeißen,
weil ich nicht auf die Idee komme, das zu verwenden. Jetzt aber. Nein, nicht Buffer 2.
Das war ein Buffer 2. So und jetzt komm. Bless RNG. Hups. Was hat jetzt für Schmerzen? Ach,
ich muss es immer noch umcasten. Ich caste. Okay, er kompiliert schon mal. Bin begeistert.
Und jetzt komm. Zeig es uns. Dass es funktioniert. Let's go. Okay, es funktioniert nicht. Jetzt
weiß ich aber nicht, warum es nicht funktioniert, ehrlich gesagt. Third Setup failed. Kann er
sich ein bisschen genauer sagen? Es sind die Dinger, die ich generiert habe mit seinem
Krempel. Warum failen die? Example Third Punkt der. Example Key der. Example Third der. Tja,
ich weiß es nicht. Irgendwie scheint das, muss ich das anders machen, aber das gucke
ich mir heute nicht mehr an. Also ich bilde mir ein, ich habe das richtige eingelesen,
aber anscheinend doch nicht. Nee, er kann es einlesen, sonst hätte er hier schon Fehler
geschmissen. Guck mal, ob eine Sache gucke ich jetzt noch, ob der irgendwie einen Spiffs
Third Example hat. Ah, komm mal. SSL-Certificate. Da macht er das doch, ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja.
Der macht es doch genauso wie wir. Und dann. Wait. Er liest das ein. Ach so, der generiert
es hier neu. Er macht im Prinzip genau das gleiche wie ich auch. Er macht genau das gleiche
wie ich auch. Aber bei ihm funktioniert es, bei mir funktioniert es nicht. Er holt sich
die Size bevor er liest. Ah. Ich hole mir auch die Size bevor ich lese. Oder? Das dürfte
keinen Unterschied machen. Er macht, er macht das hier. Er macht Key Size. Also er macht
quasi das hier. Third Size. Er macht es so. Er macht es so. Was aber eigentlich keinen
Unterschied macht? Hoffe ich mal. Vielleicht ist es falsch rum. Vielleicht steht dann was
anderes in FFS nach dem Lesen drin. Vielleicht, vielleicht kann sein. Okay. Er prüft die
Size auf. Ja wir geben die Size auch gleich mal aus. Okay. Third Setup Failed. Fick dich.
Monka Toss. So. Gucken wir mal jetzt ob er was gelesen hat. Read. Okay. 540 Bites, 609
Bites. Das ist eigentlich ziemlich gut. 609, 540 Leute. Also genauer kann es nicht sein
was ich da lese. Also. Das stimmt zumindest auf jeden Fall schon mal. Gucken wir mal in
Third Punkt H rein. 540. 540. Ja. Also. Das ist richtig. Guck mal. Sogar hier drinnen
ist, ist also. Wir lesen, wir lesen das Richtige ein. Warum das jetzt natürlich nicht funktioniert.
Hoffe. Ach. Ach. Moment mal. Das ist doch eigentlich. Das ist doch eigentlich egal.
Also sowas muss ich doch hier nicht machen. Was? Nee oder? Es geht doch normalerweise
als Pointer sonst durch. Nee. Nee. Aber. Also daran kann es doch eigentlich nicht liegen
hier. Ich meine ich mache einfach mal das gleiche was er auch macht. Äh Moment. Ah.
Ah. Wo waren wir? Leute mein Brain ist kaputt. Ich weiß nicht mal wo wir waren. Hier. Ich
kann nicht mal denken. Ich copy paste einfach nur noch. Elite Keeper Buffer. Mein Brain
ist dead. Okay. Ich kann echt nicht mal denken. Das Brain ist runtergefahren ja. Also Key
Size. Das da. Das da. Das da. Das da. Das da. Okay. Also. Also. Das ist Key Size. Key
Size. Haben wir hier auch schon. Und hier haben wir. Third. Third Size. Third Buffer.
Ich mache mal meine Buffer 1 und Buffer 2 mache ich weg. So. Äh Third Size. Heißt
bei mir Third Size. Wo macht der Reed Bites? Moment. Moment. Der macht einfach nur Reed?
Ist das ein Unterschied? Ist das ein Unterschied? Der ein Reed macht. Reed Bites. Okay. Unused.
Moment. Ist es nicht Third Buffer? Es muss Key Buffer sein. Ich sag Brain ist runtergefahren.
Okay. Third Buffer. Third. Third. Hier. Key Buffer. So. Letzter Versuch. Anarchisch
Schluss. Reicht für heute. Genug Big Brain Time gehabt. Ich hab es jetzt genau wie im
Example. Hat funktioniert? Was? Wo war der Unterschied? Wo war der Unterschied jetzt?
Reed statt Reed Bites? What the hell? Wie soll man das? Es hat funktioniert. Ja. Okay.
Den Unterschied habe ich nicht kapiert. Aber wie dem auch sagt ich muss nicht alles verstehen.
Wunderbar. Perfekt. Easy GG. Easy Clap. Easy as fuck. Clap. Kein Problem. Einfach einfach
Tutorial durchpappen. Egal. Ich mach jetzt. Eine Sache ist jetzt ja noch die mich ja noch
kurz Reiz auszuprobieren. Einfach nur ob das wirklich an einem Pointer geschiss lag oder
nicht. Nice. Das da. Das geht auch ganz schnell. Third Size. Kompiliert. 1 zu 1. Okay. Upload.
Okay. Das lag wirklich daran. Es muss es muss Pointer gestellt sein. Oder aber. Nee.
Das geht jetzt nicht. Okay. Ist mir egal. Weg. Weg. Aus für heute. Schluss. Chat. Wir
sehen uns morgen. Ich hoffe Stream hat euch gefallen. Übrigens Wahnsinn wie viele wie
viele Follower es gegeben hat in den letzten Tagen. Allein heute gab es 35 WTF. Ich hab
gedacht was ist da los. 35 Follower. Also für meine Verhältnisse ist das Ultra viel an
einem Tag. Das klingt ja so. Klingt sinnvoll. Aber vielleicht man sollte sich den Kram einfach
kopieren. Übrigens ist es wieder gelb oben rechts. Also wir sehen uns. Eventuell morgen
Bastel an der Geschichte weiter. Weil ich will jetzt mal endlich das gelbe muss ich
fixen. Das. Trägert mich. Also wir sehen uns morgen. Oder. Vielleicht ich verspreche
es nicht. Aber vielleicht morgen. Bis dann. Macht es gut. See you.